- well hello Super Trouper nation army
are we an army or nation super troopers
but we're both a nation and our soldiers
today's episode we are joined by the I
want to say what's the word for someone
that does a lot prolific great it's
elliptic oh my god you're the prolific
Sean Evans the greatest also zapable the
prolific Sean Evans legendary host of
hot ones built a spicy Empire at a dream
from one jalapeno seed planted now he's
got the Scoville chili Reaper Wow what's
the spiciest pepper
well maybe pepper I actually like the
reaper might be what you're the carrot
now he's got a whole garden of Carolina
Reapers he has interviewed the likes of
Barack Obama yep I predict a president
on hot ones who do you think it'll be
well we don't have many options right
but hopefully if it's Bernie then no
he's not eating hot ones he's not doing
that
Bernie they may like burn a hole right
you see like that
Bernie feels the burn while eating it's
like a very you can't own it extremely
internet it's like yeah it's yang
I'm surprised yang do you reach out to
people like getting to do hot once well
like pretty all of the campaign's almost
I feel like most of them have kind of
like flirted with us or reached out so
you and your well I think that if we do
it I think we want to do it in like a
bigger way like in a different sort of
thing like not just have like one person
sit down and eat ten wings but like just
set up like would have been cooled like
set up and I want to actually have like
three or four of them or like oh the hot
ones democratic debate yeah something
like that
moderated over spicy wings or something
but we have like a bigger picture thing
that we're like trying to put together
that's pretty cool yeah who's reached
out like named somebody I mean I'm
Thanks so yeah Peter yeah nice Klobuchar
uh I don't know would have to checked it
but maybe she's at it she's
worried about her Bernie Sanders yeah
like no no no every major campaign
Bernie sander I'd reached out the hot
ones and you said no not no we're trying
to what we're trying to do even you're
catching me okay we're trying to uh the
podcast I'm cornered no but what we're
trying to do is like do it in a bigger
way like we don't want to just well
maybe it'll work out that way but it's
like don't are very busy people right
now so like getting all that's okay so
are we but getting it to all line up
just right you know hmm because because
okay I don't want to tell you how to do
your show but what do you think we
should just like I think cycling I'm
three or something yes most definitely
maybe you want that one-on-one time you
want to put their feet to the pepper
fires you should get Yangon there that
would be amazing
yeah I think we're just we're just
trying to do it trying to figure out how
we get more than like one you don't I
see I see ones how it's designed it's
like you're more or less like it's like
a de facto cosine because you're like
yeah celebrate so we're just trying to
like what's a rope why but I don't
really but it is something that we're
thinking about like trying to figure out
how it is like a bigger would you what
if you do a presidential week and then
the yeah I mean that would be the thing
or like it's like it's a longer video
we're hitting on like some of the same
issues with everybody in like right like
cutting into like one episode that has
like multiple well is it I guarantee
that will get more views than all of the
televised debates combined I would watch
the Living God would you do a hot once
with Donald Trump I mean again it's like
one of those hard things where it's like
a de facto cosine so you want to avoid
politics uh a little bit the static is
like so you know it's like it's just one
of those things like I don't know if
it's like a thing that you can come back
from in the same way once you do it like
once you dive into it you watch it
it is something that's like so
in-your-face now that may be creating
that sort of escapism on Thursdays is
maybe something that's helped the brand
more than I understand you're absolutely
right
also Sean Evans is coming to truTV this
month right
February 18th hot once t v-- show has
been already canned it's in the I mean
it's in the can not cancel recorded
they've all been reported yeah you've
got to how many episodes yeah like yeah
20 and I yeah and I really do truTV by
the way that's yeah because the
impractical joke makes sense that yeah
you know there's already like an
audience that understands that crossover
so it really was for it yeah and then
they treated us really well and saw the
vision and created this pepper dome that
like when I walked out for the first
time it was crazy as like actually have
I have the video here that I pulled up
here's the first behind-the-scenes
footage of Sean walking out and to you
call it the pepper dome yeah like as
exactly as the gladiators must have felt
look at this walking out into the
Coliseum I mean really how did you feel
walking out like oh my god because ever
since we started hot ones like forever
we've been just trying to get a neon
sign no what are you crazy know exactly
what you mean I've been wanting a neon
sign since we started and we still don't
have one yeah yeah there's a lot of it
simple trying to get a neon light like
that's all we've ever wanted since we
started the show and then I've been told
time and time again that it's just an
impossible task like neon lights you
might as well ask for the moon yeah and
then I walk down here and they have like
5,000 yeah so tell so tell me Sean
you've gone from making a youtube show
to now working on a Sun credible looking
set like this tell me tell me about that
experience what's it like to be a host
of a television show for chrissake I
know well it's like so different than
you know the web show it so in what
looks like this public access a tea set
you know it's just this quiet room kind
of like how we're in right now you know
and then when you go out into this the
pepper
there's 350 people and it's such a big
thing it feels like if you were to make
something off music huge huge rowdy very
rowdy like it's in Atlanta and the
camera people we're all just talking us
like oh if you do this in LA like
everyone's blase they're only
seat-filler the regulars are the Rowdies
like yeah but and did you guys have
signs telling them to react no it would
just ended up being kind of crazy plus
it is the spicy Game Show thing like I
do remember it like one point because in
the final game it's the sort of time
thing and that's what leads to somebody
went in $25,000 prize yeah right so it's
like five four three two and they this
team got it at the last second the place
exploded like there's a French war game
and somebody yeah so the game is just
it's naturally exciting that way plus
the people were super into it they're
all hot ones fans so it was very much
like felt like we were doing a concert
for hot so you know the format you give
him the spicy do you go full spicy on
these poor fans tell me about the spice
of all these these poor people they're
walking in what are they what are they
faced with on the spice level it's
insane I mean uh it's I don't think I
don't know it is so crazy like we had a
puking problem when we were doing aisle
and a problem
we were probably at like a 20% do you
leave that in the show I haven't seen
the sort of end result of it but it'll
probably like be a little bit more
polished but it is a dangerous crazy
show we'd have medics come on not every
team even gets through the three rounds
like it's nuts are you know this is like
it's not something that you could do
with a celebrity I'm assuming yeah we
had that little joke we could never
x-factors sometimes had celebrity
edition episodes x-factor or a fear
factor how fair fair yeah so I wonder
where there is crazy yeah as a fear
factor connoisseur I was shocked but
they did stop doing the celebrity
episode though and the celebrity a god
it was like Coolio by the way just as
enough
one his episode and so I was very proud
of him he lost dear episode well but
it'll live for those who don't know was
your most tragic interview the interview
was fine it was just the collapse at the
end you know the bravado gotten the best
of Coolio there at the end and so did
you have any guests on the show who
suffered the same fate as Coolio move
any hospital rides any doctor visits
I think Christie married in there right
no no I mean on the game show oh yeah on
the game show yeah yeah I think we had
we had medics on site yeah we'd have
medics on set they'd be having to like
they'd have to meet with the contestants
and commercial breaks all the time be
like taking vitals it was [ __ ] it was
pretty crazy
anyone [ __ ] their pants um not that I
could tell but you know it's spot it's a
likely right when they do the the deep
dive documentary I'm sure that something
like I look I you know well but it was
nuts it was really it was really it's
such an intense show it really is crazy
and people are pushed to the brink like
the the worst effects that I've ever
seen of anyone on spicy food like top
ten of them are on this game show like
it's you know it's it's totally a
different thing and I've seen some crazy
stuff what are you serving them is it
just like from this beginning all out
like it's not that much food so that's
always what I'd tell the contestants and
they're coming on because it is such a
jarring thing they're nervous well
they're nerville the context of is
insane it's like okay hey you've never
been on TV before we're gonna put you in
the middle of the pepper dome put a
bunch of cameras on you feed you like
the spiciest wings imaginable and is it
the spiciest hot sauce they use on hot
ones or is it different
yeah it's hotter it's hotter than it's
Wow and why is it like proprietary did
you something yeah the sauces are made
you know for the show well that was like
a whole Rubik's Cube that we had to
solve you know I remember like very
early on even when it was just me in
like a conference room and they moved
the
a scout and I'm just drilling games and
stuff and we'd have contestants and you
know trying to figure out like because
if nobody reacts to the first wing can't
be like hot ones we're slowly right no
time nobody's making it to the first
commercial break yeah yeah yeah you know
so it comes out in such a crazy way ours
people they're back on their heels but
what I'd always say is you know we open
up the first act with the wing second
act with the wing and the third act
you're like going up this mountain
Covell and with every question you get
right like the more money you get you
have to keep eating so higher the
altitude the tougher the climb sort of
situation so you have to win the 25k you
have to basically it's it's three wings
and like a shot of hot sauce oh all the
way at the end yeah what do you call
that when the windows Christian people
like masturbate and then they wag you
late what do you call that
yeah come on what is it Dan isn't flight
flagellate it's when you whip yourself
you're sinning that's like what they're
doing yeah somebody [ __ ] their pants I'm
sure I'm sure I'm sure I'm about to [ __ ]
my pants unrelated last week he almost
did the show yeah I didn't when I don't
get when I don't know go to break early
but I when I don't poop before the show
I always I'm turtle necking are you
turtle making right now quite turtle
knocking but you know people look mock
I'm not gonna talk about [ __ ] too
much because people always like even
let's go like there's gotta be more to
talk about I have a question have you
was it hard to adjust to working on a
television set and team and like process
yeah well cause it's totally different
you know and hot ones just like here you
know you have such a small team you know
five six people in your orbit and you
know you're kind of calling the shots on
down sort of thing and so that's in a
lot of ways how hot ones is and then
when you do get this thing you know
there there's a lot more moving parts I
remember when we took the picture for
like the rap photo at the end of the
game show as like wow it's like a full
stage full of how many people if you you
know probably
I don't know it's like one of those
things where it's probably you know it
could be like I'm probably missing this
number but I think you know like we
ended up giving like cuz I shot it
around the holidays yeah I'm more than
that like probably close to a hundred
yeah boots on the ground like more the
other people do I don't know they all
are out there all seem busy and stressed
yeah they're all running around i but it
is crazy I mean I mean it's a lot it
will off it's a huge set and probably
want to capture everything so there's a
lot of cameras and yeah you know what
the budget was per episode
uh no not I don't know it's probably a
lot at least twenty five thousand for
the for the dang prize and then that's
no got a hundred people working yeah I
could start doing I think it's like one
hundred two hundred thousand three
hundred thousand maybe yeah I think
that's kind of like the minimum three
hundred thousands of minimum yeah okay
chill John Evans we've come what about
the IP you on the IP no I don't touch
the I I don't have you know the IP is uh
[Music]
locked in a box with me on the outside
but but I'm not a mmm you know is that a
problem no not really I mean I think you
know at this point we've been doing it
for like so long and you know who knows
where it goes or like how big you always
just feel like you catch lightning in a
bottle so like month over month you just
kind of like build on that but um I
don't know what if you think about it in
like terms of like your career being
like a much longer time period you know
like is this one project of many is
everything you know what I mean and if
it is I mean ultimately like you know
maybe I'm an idiot for thinking this way
but I was just like lucky to end up here
even in like this position and I'm a
chicken wing talk show host and stuffs
pretty good so then you start thinking
about that and now yeah and it's got a
smile and that's a healthy way to look
at it I don't care what if I were if I
was you I'd be bitter well of course you
would be but if I was you because you
made you are comments you writing your
partner Chris right right whose
hey Chris can we could you just say hi
do you know what he looks like
no I've seen him in those who know no
those are those crazy that there is he's
active so he is the you guys are
partners Yeah right
mm-hmm so if I was you guys yeah yeah I
can't imagine we take some notes because
you guys are hot ones you guys made the
show I mean I I just I don't know who
has that yeah it's gotta be this complex
right okay you might say it's
complicated yeah yeah well you know it's
that's that's our goal like in the
context of right are you more citizens
yeah I mean Tim of the TV show you man
over the TV show yeah if we're lucky
enough we'll run it back it's gonna be
gone yeah so it's you can always
renegotiate stuff no yeah exactly and
it's it's a good team man well last time
I saw you you were feeling
underappreciated yeah well I feel a
little bit better now you're feeling
more appreciated that's good at least
there's that yeah exactly I feel are you
feeling more appreciated are much more
appreciated much more appreciated last
time we met you're sure yeah and
well-deserved thank you I appreciate
that Ethan it's very very well-deserved
and Chris are you feeling uh very very
very much more appreciated give me some
put your hands up if you're feeling
appreciated what I'm good if you're more
yeah he pudding he's putting on very
high yeah he's putting up as high as you
can and that's an important thing too
you know for for us to feel that you
know absolutely fully that's kind of
like what I was supposed to be yeah but
I need a pretty face too bright
yeah I need a pretty yeah what is Chris
do who look where's Chris is is the
mastermind behind first we feast which
before hot ones why James Beard
award-winning website and then uh you
know he's the one who came up to me and
is like I have this idea what if we like
interviewed celebrities but had the meat
increasingly spicy like really good
chicken wings over the question
interview and then I was like so what
did he wait
what was your what we were just yeah we
were just uh we were just chummy you
know we just had a good vibe good
creative energy and we never really
worked on anything before but we just
had like a good sort of like
water-cooler vibe to each other and so
you know we'd spent a lot of time
chatting and it was just all off of vibe
and then he had this idea it's not like
we had high aspirations for it or
anything you know like throwing this
idea out into the ether and then uh the
way it hit my ear is just like so funny
I'm like we got a we got a strike
there's one of those ideas sometimes
ideas occur me where I'm like that's
genius but then you almost don't trust
yourself you're like well it's also kind
of stupid yeah and that feeling well we
it's not like we ever thought it would
end up in a point like this you know
like we thought we could be an Internet
sideshow for a little bit and do this
thing and have fun with it but we never
but it sounds like you did have a very
like focused vision from the beginning
yeah that's true I think but that
combined with the way the audience
rallied around it you know and it's we
didn't have a big audience at first but
they were cold like they were so into it
and they were like we can't wait for the
next step they had such an appetite for
it yeah and that really is what fueled
us because we're like okay well we can't
just like cycle through people and have
meat scorching hot wings like if this is
gonna have legs we have to like combine
this hook with it being a very
fascinating interview show that could
stand on its own as an interview show
and then if we can combine these things
with the post-production then we might
have something yeah and then that
started probably you know we started
aligning with with maybe bigger profile
stars and all of that just kind of
happened at the same time at a time
where even you know the the YouTube
space is growing you know like it all
had to happen at like a very specific
time I don't know you guys have gotten
so big at this point I don't even think
you can have youtube stars anymore to be
frank with you Sean I think they are
below your pedigree well I I but I thank
you I think I don't even think you can
know [ __ ] with someone like me anymore
no no no I that's a me yes no I think
that uh I think the move is that you
want to keep a foot in both worlds you
know like like
I kind of like having a name a youtuber
you want on you don't want you to don't
I don't blame you
well I don't know but but I'm but you
know you're kind of you help me in this
space you know what I mean like I'm not
you know like you you understand I think
the YouTube zeitgeist in fabric yes
better than I do
hmm I don't know it's not yet but we
believe we yes yes
whoo-hoo I would who do you think would
be the best interview and then who do
you think would know I'm dead serious
I don't think you want youtubers on your
show it's a it's well one that would be
great is created by oh yeah yeah
PewDiePie but see is that too
controversial for your show I mean I've
I've I've never I don't I'm not that
yeah you don't know that deep but um is
he's kind of hard to get to
yeah he's so busy he's all over the
place he's not here that would yeah
right
but like I'm gonna genuinely try to
think of like david dobrik would
probably huge yeah and we've hung out a
couple times and yeah like i think that
on the shortlist you know like when you
ask like well you're like you're like
when you win you're in the position
where like i've got Shaq available this
week I've got who's the one that's
coming out next week
Margaret Margot Robbie and I've got
david dobrik it's like wow come on but
but I think that keeping you know like
one foot in the in that sort of
mainstream one foot okay would you have
on this isn't even that good of a game
would you have on okay we're not gonna
get a station he's like the new a
douchebag of YouTube he faked his
girlfriend's death and then yeah but it
was no she acted like she really died
and cried and everything but she didn't
bet he also called her ghost like on
them away G board oh wow it's awesome
I'd watch that yeah yeah I'll have to
dig in to dig into the creek yeah do
some recon Jane know I might be James
Charles but he's you
yeah use huge then I convey industries
here people the thing is on YouTube -
people are so toxic the fanbase is like
I feel the people would generally get
angry there's a lot of someone on that
they don't like it does seem like when
we do Wars
yeah there's it's a weird thing
mainstream media people are always like
cool we love that yeah well it is it's a
little strange
I mean Shane Dawson yeah I feel like
that would hit right but absolutely
though yeah I think he would shoot his
pants though I don't know anything about
it but I have a feeling I got more
questions don't worry that aired a dare
- dare okay let me so since the last
time you were on here you have achieved
what nobody thought was possible
well Gordon Ramsay yeah was that your
biggest white whale your ultimate guest
yeah I really was I really think that
the internet peer pressured us into
because yeah I feel like he was feeling
that same thing like he came in knowing
that this was a day that would like live
forever on an Internet because he went
all out he did the sketches yeah you
guys did all this crazy promo I mean he
was all in with you guys yeah I mean it
was one of those things like when we
first started the show that was the
biggest request and it gotten so big
that it doesn't matter like I could post
like a picture of me like like a burger
that I'm eating at a restaurant and all
the comments are like Gordon Ramsay show
and so it wasn't so much that you wanted
him it was that not the fates had
brought you both together well I always
think of I always think of that means
the show kind of in that way is that I
you know the fact that you end up in
this feedback loop with YouTube like one
of the good things about it is your
audience can like really tell you
exactly who they want on the show I'm
sure that that even shapes and informs
what you have for yeah because you can
see who the audience is and that's why
the people watching it feel like a
special connection to the thing so I
always I always that's important to us
not that like we need to do every
episode exactly what the audience wants
all the time cuz yeah you know sometimes
the magic of hot ones is that we take
somebody in showmen in like a deck
Quentin you know that would be amazing
worked for for jumped what he did for
John Travolta that's a big dead air
someone they didn't expect and breathe
new life see my comment less random but
worse but like Gordon you could tell it
felt that morning you know I still
remember as in LA is very cloudy it felt
like a playoff game or something you
know like going through the office that
morning right
buttoned up you know like a business
trip sort of thing well they won't let
us halfway on that for sure they were
right because that episode hit 50
million now he is which is absolutely
now tell me was it like to sit face to
face with Gordon Ramsay were you nervous
to serve Him yeah dude woah yeah like
let's start with the food sure of all
the food you know I think he he'll play
into that like it's not like he's gonna
come on hot ones where we have gotten a
lot better
I'm when you served me they were like
very old yeah you care it came at a at a
rough time in our they were sitting up
for like yeah yeah we're still in our
infancy but that's it's kind of cool
though as we go back so far were you the
first Youtube guess that we have I think
maybe I would I think maybe you had one
other I think I maybe was think if you
guys I think you guys blaze that trip
and I do I'm very happy I have to smile
yeah to what the episode we did yeah my
favorite thing that we ever did but I
will say that the wings were I fear if I
was if I was if they weren't slathered
in bacteria killing poison I would have
that word yeah we had a lot of those
complaints early on we have turned that
around and so the wings that Gordon ate
were there pretty good wings I stand by
him okay but he's gonna come in there
and he's gonna like
from the wings like at one point I think
he was even like is this expired it says
like bottle like that was just like was
it really expired no like the sauce that
we made that he pulled up wasn't even
didn't wasn't even around it was
nicotine he was making that up yeah yeah
that yeah but that's it that's that's
the Gordon Ramsay side and that's what
makes him such an amazing entertainer
but he's he was a teddy bear and was
awesome to work with and he's the man
like I'm a huge fan yeah I love his uh
they could watch every single day yeah
Wow yeah he's and when he left after it
was all done tell me did you guys all be
like I can't believe that just happened
yeah there are certain times or we're
just like hugging like we wanted
something you know that means it's a
Super Bowl exactly so at the end we're
just you know me and Chris went out
immediately it was like 1 o'clock in the
afternoon we're just like grabbing old
fashions at the bar you know I knew it
was a masterpiece yeah yeah the fact
that it happened but then you do have a
lot of pressure on that moment and on
that thing yeah but we felt like we just
executed it and when we posted the video
jubilation
yeah and then we had like a little
teaser lots of teasers were getting
crazy hype yeah as a video dropped was
the immediate reaction was insane views
right yeah massively yeah never
something that we've never done before
and I don't know if we'll do it after 50
million that's that's no joke that's
high level [ __ ] pretty popular but
something that is not a music video yeah
long-form yeah yeah interview come on
but that's all that that was just the
fans I was just like that was the
internet making that happen
Sean Evans the spicy captain we are
gonna take a quick commercial break
we'll be right back we have so so so so
so much more dead air ahead and on good
content I mean presumably guys we'll be
right back after this short do you guys
got to cut me off Dan because I can
never just throw it to the brake I got
just be like
hello and welcome to the sponsored
portion of the h3 podcast today we're
wasting a little bit of time for the
bathroom break we've pre-recorded this
because we are don't have any sponsors
today we have sponsors on friday's
episode so today I would like to let you
know that Teddy fresh has a brand new
collection out don't ever talk to me or
my son again hoodie by popular demand
has been restocked beautiful gorgeous
forget about it all these are brand new
Ted all-over hoodie MMS and white I'm
not white power this name is fine back
in Ventura if you wore red there was
like this gang peer pot and if you wore
red it meant white powers like a word
thin so this is the white power hoody
not a good way to it but if you like red
and cream colors it has nothing to do
with racial supremacy this one sold out
so unfortunately you can't get it
anymore but here it is it's very cool
the one that L is wearing is one of the
most beautiful pieces ever designed yes
that was the sound of my phone going off
and I didn't mute it look at this it's
so beautiful
came out so beautiful stand up and and
just show it off or julilah go ahead
don't be shy show it off yes Teddy fresh
with rainbows and clouds give it a twirl
show the back it's an endless sky my god
is beautiful our idea
alright careful about you're gonna tear
the hole oh this is sold out guys so
don't even think most of these pieces
will not be back to ya oh yeah don't
even think about trying to buy this
that's why you got to be a little bit
faster this came out only on Thursday of
last week and we have a lot sold out or
we are going to get more of the long
sleep I've got to be quick you got to be
quick out here on the Teddy fresh this
is let me click this because
you really the whole overview this is
called the acid trip and I love it
kind of our new acid logo and then on
the on the arm sleeve the arm sleeve
what up
you've got these uh blots there's not
really good photo of it yeah well but
it's like obscured by the shirt
you get the idea though regula mm-hmm
you got it in navy you got it in what
all right forget about it we still have
some of those this one we have a lot of
it's pretty outrageous but I'll tell you
what I love it I think it's beautiful
came out beautiful these are sewn on
patches so try to find that look at that
it's hot super hot fire designed by
yours truly not me
ela this one I named you may know ribbed
for your pleasure I thought that was
funny name
ela vetoed it but then I went to the
peanut gallery and they all said it was
funny so we went with ribbed for your
pleasure and but the next shirt you I
designed this one I drew it I designed
it I did everything
it says teddy fresh and green looks like
grass and then the Y goes up into a
flower and then there's a honey there's
like a bumble bee here I'm wearing it
right now it's embroidered it looks
amazing I love how it came out and yes
I'm very proud of myself on this design
you like do you have any words of
encouragement for me I like it thank you
anything else I like it anything
additional I do not like it that's don't
why would you say that reversible twelve
bucket hat how long we've been going
down three 1/2 minutes it's not that bad
did so this is a black buck a hat with
our logo except psych you put it inside
out and you got frickin cool ass print
that looks dope also the same as the red
and matches the hoodie cool ripped red
bucka hat
psych it's got prints inside that's what
makes it reversible folks and there you
have it so that's what we've got going
on here on the Teddy fresh calm website
get it Wow supplies last it's in high
demand that people are
or pounding at the gates lesson remember
that the guy at the mall why won't you
let me in I demand to be able to shop
these are the kinds of people are
pounding at the gates of the TAFE fresh
website so get it
get in there quick while supplies last
right ela what do you mean no your this
is your company yours
you that's you know you can help me sell
this [ __ ] mm-hmm all right I think we've
got we've done enough here right Dan
yeah okay okay thank you guys we're
right back with Sean Evans we are back
with Sean Evans Chris was in here what
were you guys talking about oh well
you're talking to a queer talking about
a David Letterman Jesus and marrow and
then they were talking about hot ones
because oh so I so you're just he was
filling me in on not what I said
wait Letterman was on what Jesus and
marrow the Showtime show they're like
these two guys they actually did how I'm
still worse so Letterman knows about hot
ones yeah he was saying yeah I love Dave
so yeah that's why Kristen's telling me
but he was I'm Nam playing telephone
with like the information but he was
like that Letterman said Jesus Mara like
I saw you guys eating hot wings
so now they just filling me in now that
you've got Gordon Ramsay yep who is this
next person that the fates you feel are
are pulling you gravity yeah I think
like the loudest names now are probably
like Keanu Reeves or something wow it's
I can see him doing it Keanu yeah yeah
yeah so that's that's right now probably
the loudest name but then I'm like what
then you know all of a sudden I'm just
I'm just trying to just catch white
whales all the time yeah and what we're
in well Will Smith would be very mean
tasked with uh-oh that's hot yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know Billy Eilish was on
your show I first of all I'm a fan she's
mega Talent my god it got it's at 31
million views in what like six months
I'm
winning the prize the second biggest
episode yes it is yeah I was a little
bit well I knew it would be huge like
sometimes right sometimes you know like
speaking of audience or whatever I
remember when we dropped that like you
know our audience like who like whatever
weight she's enormous now you know
here's I think like it was just so we
knew that it would be bigger like than
the hyper on it like we knew it would be
big but but yeah I don't know it's
that's great yeah I think like it's like
bigger than you know like Kevin Hart
episode like whatever I'll tell you that
I think the third most popular is Shaq
at 19 makes sense to me which was one of
the most memorable episodes of all time
let me go in and maybe you have some you
have some big meme episodes
oh my goodness this is one of the top
names of the century by the way how Jack
is such a such a character
he's awesome we went down to Atlanta to
shoot what they claim my podcast for
playing this no I don't I don't touch
the IP I don't have lawyers I by the way
my own place recently took down one of
our videos worldwide block I did x2 oh
oh
I said Sean complex took down our whole
entire podcast you did I didn't get well
why I didn't understand what you that
meant I said for I said can you do me a
solid as a homing in for this I said you
were talking I thought it sounded like
you did it
I thought you were talking about it
being like a news event like they took
down your video in Florida I think it
just sent it to the wrong people
we cut it yeah like what is this I was
yeah they were I was like I don't know
you've been I was like this there's
there's the powers that be are taken
even this videos down like get this up
on the blog ASAP
well if I didn't understand if our um if
our podcast gets blocked worldwide I'm
coming I'm gonna let you know listen you
got the person on the phone right you're
pretty big up in complex organization
but I don't think I don't think I don't
know if I am I don't know but but like
you know like I don't know who - yeah I
wouldn't know I wouldn't know who to
email about that I don't think you don't
have a person that does your digital
rights you don't know who that is Chris
would know yeah probably Chris Chris you
know
Chris how are you and Chris how high is
Chris in the complex organization he's
we feast yeah yeah he's a big deal this
is a big deal yeah Chris would know who
to eat miss get on the month you had a
problem Chris would know put Pat on the
no idea I'm on Chris Chris Chris when
you're okay okay Chris Chris can help us
Chris what is your title within the
complex organization what do you say GM
of Phrygia fierce beast what is general
manager yeah yeah General Motors General
Motors the first week he's CEO of
chicken wing so how many people do you
report to Chris I mean how many people
are above you and I'm the head of the
first we feast brand okay which ladders
into complex networks so if you guys
need something done okay so wait so when
caught one there's decisions made about
first we feast do you need to go to
anyone or your though you'd the buck
stops with you we make creative
decisions but of course they're you know
legal and and you know their revenue
decisions that'll be collaborative
collaboratively yes okay and do you own
a piece of the IP of first we face are
you an entertainment lawyer yeah I know
some that's the problem when you create
a show like you guys it's a runaway
success you don't get that you don't get
the lawyer involved early enough because
you just don't even know into but at the
time that I came out like who's to know
you know that it wasn't like that I
think that uh the the things that made
hot ones possible like a thing that
could be successful
we're not things that even existed when
the show started here's what I here's my
game plan for you guys and you're doing
it right Chris are you listening he's
all yours just for both you guys yeah
yeah yeah and you're doing it you're
doing it perfectly you get it so big
you've got the TV show you've got the
coop show is already
got this incredible momentum that's
uncontrollable that's when you say we
quit and you mean it address me I know
this from people who have done this with
the biggest IPS you can imagine that I
can't say but you there knows what I'm
talking about you say if we don't get a
piece of the action we're done and do
you know what they're gonna say yes you
get it maybe maybe or don't go in with
this attitude or no I think like at some
point you'll just be like at some point
it's like a thing any point you're gonna
with the body of work you know that you
feel fine turning the page on it yeah
you know what I mean at that point I
guess you seemed content um life is good
that's that's like no you well I think
you're good actually I would say that
Ethan I yours I've gone to quite a bit
well there you have it ela apparently
you're wrong
do you think I'm overstepping my bounds
ela perhaps that's alright it's pockets
this is just interesting but no I did
too and I yeah I just saw one I like
this I want to look after these guys
yeah yeah I think that that's where it
comes from is just sort of like the
creative flag you know that you're
trying to fly and imagine Jerry Seinfeld
didn't have a piece of Seinfeld the guys
were oh he's like oh well yeah I made 20
million dollars no cepheid's a
billionaire eula wool hot ones ain't
Seinfeld well not yet Yeah right right
but I could see syndication can you send
a gate YouTube video no come on we need
to know what's going on here but he's
happy you're happy that's what I care
about
thank you I appreciate him but that is
true because that's like what comes
after us is just totally the wild wild
west where it's true like nobody owns
the pipes anymore you know and people
are able to pop from inside their
bedrooms or their garages or like with
one camera or something and maybe you do
end up in a position where something
larger can be the sunlight in the water
that helps that seed grow into something
bigger or maybe you don't need that so
it's a good lesson
and to whoever's watching this that has
an idea for the future like whatever you
know and in a way to lock it down and
own the biggest part you can while being
strategic about how you can make it grow
so on the TV show you just you're
getting a fee per episode is that out
that's how it usually works yeah yeah
exactly good good at 20 episodes there's
a big order for the first season game
shows are awesome I always think about
the the jobs and entertainment that no
one ever leaves and it seems like no one
ever leaves they don't show no one ever
leaves a game show and that's because
you can just you can shoot 20 episodes
and like some thank you help so you guys
shot 20 episodes how long do you shoot
those in um we were in Atlanta for two
weeks to do that you know and how long
is that season gonna run a truTV I may
not remember that's up to that's up to
people who you know not me but like yeah
you can that could be I don't know I
could end up being like like on a game
show or whatever you can end up doing
like a year's worth the show isn't like
less than a month or so you know in a
couple weeks I was the scheduling
grueling yeah it's crazy it's crazy
especially at that time that was
definitely I'm probably in the middle of
the busiest two three months that I've
ever had in my life
mmm you still made it here so made it
well of course of course I made it here
but uh but because we were ending one
season had that like around the holidays
break wood you know most people would
use to spend time with family and no no
no hammer that up and then hammer up
like the next season of the show that
we're doing now and so that was all
happening like 1 2 3 like back to back
to back so you're on the tail end of
this extremely busy period yes I must
feel so productive yeah yeah it feels
good and then I also feel - like right
now it feels like all right will you
just shovel the driveway almost done and
then it just like snows again yeah but
it's all good stuff like it's all a
blessing it's just you know
opportunity's beginning other
opportunities and then just trying to
make the most of out of all of them
mm-hmm I think that shows gonna be hit I
can't wait to watch it
I'm gonna DVR that [ __ ] right when I get
a she ate that do you know that work do
you get views on DVR like that
the braiding yeah right because they're
big into DVR okay that's great yeah yeah
DVR that I was wondering how they do
ratings on TV it's just they can't that
into the rating okay good oh yeah kids I
always think about that like when they
do album sales and stuff and they're you
know what I mean I'm like now there's a
total [ __ ] yeah I'm kind of like
what is it they do I know you know about
this feel that they these artists start
bundling their albums in when you buy
something else and then it counts as a
sales like you buy like a oh and you got
a free yeah you buy like a [ __ ] a
towel a towel and they're like oh you
got a free album of new of a new iPhone
update and then they do YouTube and then
that counts as a sale all kinds of
tricks so what I'm gonna be doing for
Sean is setting up I wonder if like I
could set up a thousand TV yeah in the
yard go into like a Best Buy or
something and then CPR maybe yeah DVR
farm yeah oh good you won't need it
though
how's your love life now that you're a
big star it's good yeah that's good yeah
expand on that yeah yeah you know I'm
dating yeah tell me who's the lucky lady
well I you know like if you're following
on Instagram and could figure that out
yeah what's her name Natasha and how
long you guys been dating like a year
and a half I have to say she's very
beautiful thank you yeah she is she is a
model yeah yeah she's like a Miss
California and stuff
did she win Miss California yeah Miss
California this state notorious for the
most beautiful women in it
you're a girlfriend won the title yeah
yeah who would have thought do you know
her as Miss California yeah no yeah just
Natasha
[Music]
wow it's great Sean Evans pulling miss
California boy yeah I mean not your
handsome guy you dress well you look
good but did you imagine yourself
pulling Miss California
that's I'm saying like I did you need
your IP and stuff but I'm like laughs
yeah [ __ ] IP when yeah well we were just
like friends for a long time like she
does the same sort of thing like she's
on camera and stuff so we were just
friends for a long time and then ended
up you know you made a move yeah move
what'd you say I think it was like well
I think this is one of those things were
just like hanging out and then we were
just like just kept hanging out and then
talking the next day and then that
turned into like a year and a half sort
of thing and a couple drinks it was her
mama where you asked her out
were you like hey bro she like hey I'm
interested in you like how do you not to
that moment oh I can't really I mean I
think it was just uh just kid I don't
know just kicking it if I'm a very very
natural moment they need to ask for
consent do you ask for consent
did your wife like herb the first time
you guys had sex did you ask for consent
at every moment I'm still a virgin
yeah yeah I'm assuming too much mmm
John Evans Wow how far we've come
this is a spicy pod yeah hearts racing
over here are you in love
yeah I'd say okay you guys tell each
other you love each other Wow do you
guys watch The Bachelor yeah we watched
it last night
we forgot to watch it wasn't a good app
I don't change the subject you actually
did it was a good app the guy he like
cut is he cut his face open oh right the
fame walk golf cart and he matched his
glass against his head [ __ ] and then
because they would kept they kept click
betting that he had this like permanent
scar on his face but it turns out he
just walked into a golf club yeah yeah
you just what he walked into a golf cart
and then when he walked into the golf
cart he was like stunned and then like
slammed his glass against his head so he
had this like enormous gash that they're
trying to cover up the whole time that's
I remember there was helicopter rides is
a good episode I've got
you gotta feel pretty good do that
you're dating Miss California
I'm just looking at Shauna being The
Bachelor this guy right here did ya see
so let's carry it over so you guys uh
IPA she you guys live both in New York
currently no she lives in California but
I so I spent so much time back and forth
that is a lot of traveling but I'm on
that I'm on that flight I'm on that
flight like every week I hate you know
so you live in New York she lives in LA
how often you guys get to see each other
like as many days is not like we
probably I spend as much I at this point
probably spend as much time in LA as I
do in New York are you gonna move to LA
what's going on here yeah why are you in
New York
well Kris is in New York the whole
operations in New York you come out here
to New York so we come out here to shoot
and then like sometimes like we'll
travel with the editor or whatever so
it's a show that'll just kind of it's
like a traveling show so where my home
base isn't all that important one way or
the other but the whole operation is a
New York they fly you first-class that
was a that was a win you know it took me
it took me years to get to that point
but uh yeah starting starting right now
well you know what when they fly your
ass that much you got a flying comfort
no it's like total GameChanger
yeah you know like you know there's so
many red eyes that you're like whatever
but like not that not that it's like you
know I don't know it's not a sob story
or shows that in your agreement they
have to fly first class now or yeah I
don't know that i don't know the letter
of the law in that in the contract or
anything but i feel like you've arrived
I feel like I've there's a good chance
that when I check into my flight that
the thing coming back is gonna be a good
a good seat know increasingly it seems
to be going that way so it surprises you
when you check and you don't know what
your seat yeah well sometimes there's
only so many there's only so many at the
front and then we have to we have to
move so like last second and just grab
the next fly and so do you fly with the
rest of the crew well we have like an LA
crew and we shoot in LA there's
New York who travels on the plane maybe
Chris will travel Dom Chris isn't close
[Laughter]
they call it the Shawn close the curtain
on you Chris literally he turns his head
yeah yeah he's like cnl a loser yeah
that's beautiful
what else we got Oh bill burr was on was
he difficult be honest because he was
like bill burr yeah ruined my life and
Theo's we talked about it really
Theo von what happened he's just he's
just very difficult he's my family had a
think we had a Redemption episode
redemption yeah which went well yeah it
was Redemption yeah yeah I can time I
had a whole Redemption on the first time
he put me on antidepressants literally
what yeah it was that bad no way I swear
to God so how was your experience with
Bill Bert and to be honest because he
doesn't care he doesn't listen yeah yeah
no no it was actually it was it was a
good positive really positive experience
like there's definitely some anxiety
because like you could go on YouTube and
see like you know it's like the biggest
Bilborough him like yeah destroy but no
it's pretty positive there's a positive
experience it was a you know I was
definitely like a little bit you know
there's certain episodes that maybe you
walk in and they have a different kind
of pressure to him and that definitely I
felt like that yeah you know but it was
a good positive shoot experience
definitely how do you do with the wings
did he eat them all it was great yeah he
well he like he understands cuz I think
hot ones at its core is just like
naturally a comedy showcase so he
understood the hook and it was like yeah
my thing is to like sweat through this
thing so he you know it's not like he
needed any selling on the concept like
you didn't like he understood it so yeah
Hugh goes in there and I think he did
find it like a novelty bizarre
experience you know so I think that uh
it was it went like that was one of
those where we were like high-fiving at
the end
Scarlett Johansson you even had on yeah
I mean that's a list yeah how did you
look in person she's uh she's amazing
she was actually like that was probably
the most hyped sort of after the shoot
thing that we've ever had went that well
and it was like kind of like a crazy
hard season to pull off like we were
just just like a lot of you know just it
can be a roller coaster once you're in
the production because it's just all
moving so fast and then uh that was the
last shoot of the thing and then
everyone was going on vacation alright
Scarlett so it had like so much on it
and she was like amazing through it did
you were you ever close enough at any
point to smell her no because when
you're sitting at that table it's just
all you get his spy so I get his wings
okay and did you say anything about me
I'm just kidding oh yeah yeah I'm just
trying to make obviously yeah just being
stupid right ela it's like bad joke yeah
that's exactly what it is I just trying
to make a life here
NAT Natalie Portman did she say anything
about me I'm trying to yeah I think she
said she asked about you she subscribes
and Halle Berry you had on actually I
think she has a restraining order so she
probably didn't mention me no I think so
yeah this is my joke section section you
know you're a dad now did these make you
uncomfortable then just not yet it's not
that good I've you wrote those jokes
buckle up the thing is like I want you
know yeah yeah buckle up whoo I'm
curious would you ever have someone like
OJ Simpson on the show that would be
epic yeah yeah I mean like there's a
certain the internet enos of it all like
kind of is one of those things I don't
know I don't live that yeah exactly I
don't think it's worth it what about our
Kelly you ever got out now how [ __ ]
hats they have the head take the they
convicted a criminal's episode yeah or
do criminal I like a criminals version
for sure
like the gunner like here here it's like
monetary part one is called hot ones
dark side Kevin Spacey after dark it'd
be a problem
hot ones problem a tan saled cancelled
okay they have Kevin Spacey you have
Bill Clinton you have oh gee Simpson
obviously are Kelly who else Gila Bill
Cosby would be fantastic would you have
Oh J on the pod no I would have a
combative episode with him okay I
wouldn't be I wouldn't have him on I
propped about RF you got me scared he I
think he would [ __ ] I think he might
kill me I wouldn't be scared but I don't
think that he should be on any show and
you know it trips me out I see women
like I saw a video of him at a club
dancing with women I was like you know
he killed his wife right right like what
it becomes I was like you're [ __ ]
around with OJ that guy killed his last
wife he got her I don't know people
always have those fans that will be in
denial yeah I guess like our Kelly I'm
sure it still has do you I think our
Kelly lost them all
yeah maybe there's only there's a couple
left Michael Jack you you would you ever
touch Michael Jackson the topic of
Michael Jackson you have opinion about
that or would you say I have no comment
yeah I mean well if you don't have a
horse in there like why throw but I
don't know I uh don't say anything right
not worth it yeah it's not worth that's
that's I have no special yeah let me
help you he be great hot ones if he was
alive the meltdown of that being amazed
yeah well well do you have anything you
want to ask you well are you gonna tell
him about who's our guest
uh or did you yeah I'm just having a
really awkward moment so you once asked
me
whoo my dream get would we get on hot
ones whoo do you remember who what I
said
who'd you say I don't remember Papa John
oh but guess what I've been and Papa
John's coming he's coming here on what
they do next week Monday
he's coming next Monday that's my corner
dude so weird I don't even remember how
that well so I remember a fan randomly
emailed us and he says you guys Papa
John the real Papa John made an
Instagram account and we're like that's
weird we click it it has like literally
20 followers his hand was like the real
Papa John or some [ __ ] like that
but then there's some photos there that
it was like around Thanksgiving and yeah
some of the photos were like it looked
pretty personal like you see the family
or whatever our big table we did reverse
image searches they didn't show up
anywhere okay
follow drop a DM hey papa
big fan and then this person starts
responding to me and i think i'm being
trolled and so I keep saying make you
have to make a story you have to make a
story saying hey this is Papa with your
face and he's funny he keeps he doesn't
quite get there like he makes a video
where goes
hey it's Papa it's me he but he doesn't
say hey it's like h3 surely it's me and
I'm still wondering where's all this
comp where's this [ __ ] coming from but
then he eventually made one that said
Papa blast shoutout to Ethan from h3h3
production and that's when we knew we
were doing with the real Papa whoa and
so he's flying out anyway yada yada yada
we have a long illustrious we we should
have a lot in common we talked we talked
on the phone for 15 minutes I was giving
him some customer feedback I was getting
there's a
of PI's Pappajohn PI's going out
unsliced just one piece that's what's
happening right now yeah it's an
epidemic it's an epidemic
Wow so he's coming here so we thought so
we talk shop and about pizza yeah
something I know a lot about so he flies
out to he's flying out on his private
jet I offered him to fly him just I
don't know why you made me do that
either I'm like he's Papa Johnny's a
billionaire he's got his own jet Tila
goes just okay I want this guy to come
here so I don't want it to seem like
we're asking so much of him I'm coach so
anyway he's flying his uh his private
plane out to Burbank just for the show
coming here to the H Street podcast
studio Papa John there's a whole pop up
pizza conspiracy that's been mounted
against him Sean well you guys got to
get to the bottom of yeah we are yeah
and it's the master interviewer I'd like
you for you to pitch me some questions
if you have some I'd have to dive into
that but he seems to be really in a
moment he's having it he's an open book
to I think well what is you know
probably you know it probably feels like
you lost everything how he ended up here
I said to myself
the only chance Pappajohn ever come on
the show see if he loses everything
yeah but I think you know is my gut is
to just be like just give him space you
know he's probably not a lot to get off
his chest yeah why I wouldn't I wouldn't
try to get too granular in the interview
you know I'd be broad and then just sort
of like sit back because he's probably
just been spending a lot of time stewing
and absolutely you know what he's it's
just him in the wilderness Pro yeah well
oh I don't he's in like [ __ ] Montana
I don't know he but I stay like that
Ohio but he's like Papa John's like
super rich right oh yeah he's a
billionaire
yeah or very close to it but he's just
picturing himself out on the out in the
snow Kentucky he actually owns the
biggest house in Kentucky
so guys so I think I'll have I don't
know if if I order Pappajohn pizza and
will that insult the man is that a right
you don't use a majority he's a majority
shareholder so he make yeah he's still
getting a piece of the pie even if it is
unsliced is he worked up about the
unsliced thing oh that was the message
that got him to respond
it's like he's and tell him what
happened to us when he was the aiming
him and I we had a taste test and the
PIA Papa John came on slice and there's
picture of me holding up on sliced pizza
like this but it's bigger than just that
that wasn't just like a one-time
somebody yeah some people now it's been
happening to them to open it it's a
pizza epidemic are you scared about
coronavirus you know I started off
that's a good question I've been
thinking about it cuz I did start off
you know you've watch the nightly news
or whatever and you're like no great
like they got another virus or something
you know and then they'll be like you
know six people have died and I'm always
like you know I don't feel like that's
like enough even to when sometimes
they're giving out like vaping
statistics and they're like all 50
people or not but I'm like a but like a
billion people are doing that so like
yeah pretty good that sounds about like
what I'd expect it to be I guess that's
right ballpark it yeah so anyways like
but with this Chrome virus so that's why
I started and I even told Chris I'm like
it's another another scare tactics thing
you know this is more just like fear
being sold to us sort of thing but I
don't know now I don't know now more
develops the more develops the I'm
starting to back away from my position
yeah well it's it's worse than SARS it's
a far surpassed the infections that SARS
had already SARS in 33 days infected as
many people as corona did and 11 days
and now it's skyrocketed passive less
lethal but much more contagious and most
dangerous of all Shawn there's a
two-week incubation period in which the
virus can spread SARS could only spread
that's a WoW symptom yeah it's a oh yeah
and five million people left Wuhan
before the quarantine was imposed
everywhere in the world so we shall see
you'll be fine only like your grandma
will die from it has she she missed that
boat already oh she's passed yeah I'm
sorry for your loss
it's okay you know the real risk though
is that because so many people get ill
is what's happening wuhan okay the
facilities get overwhelmed and nobody
can get medical care for any reason
there's somebody sick so you're in this
wormhole I'm I was I was extremely
worried even though in there and I've
proven to be right so far Allah it's got
all these Twitter accounts that is
falling yeah what is your what's your
news intake like these days there's this
dude dr. Fink
okay know on whose eyes I watched I like
rah I like Robin Quivers Howard Stern
yeah and she's okay no I listen to ABC
News their hourly for the headlines I
don't I'm not into deep are you know I'm
that but you know I was just worried
about you you know what I mean sometimes
sometimes people they can have like a
real appetite for that for the headlines
and you know I don't care so wrapped up
and it's just the coronavirus really
interests me because what I was seeing
was very alarming but people didn't seem
to be taking it very seriously but now
they are because like that's that was me
I was flipped because like the World
Health Organization wasn't declaring an
emergency which was alarming me they did
people were not you know stopping place
to China which they're now doing so I'm
feeling better now that the world has
finally realized and by the way the
people in China are full the people in
Wuhan bro 50 million people quarantined
are [ __ ]
China's [ __ ] I don't know what's gonna
happen
I feel awful for those people yeah well
that's pretty much all we've got here
Shawn
tell me let's tell me ultimately that no
it's a circle back if you found out you
had the corona virus what would you and
you had five days to live what would you
be well just died what would you do
would you say well do them at Vegas or
something and just and just crash and
burn but maybe I don't know maybe go to
like a national park and and and like
soak it all in
mmm probably more my vibe but not sure I
don't know hopefully it's the thing I
don't have what is your girlfriend more
interested in would you bring her
obviously yeah you'd have to you got to
go out you got to flame out together you
know would she be more into Vegas or
National Park Nash actually tough call
that's a--that's a coin flip for sure
maybe I both would have to have um for
both yeah that's true I think split that
what would you drink a corona I think
Frank across old Clanker Corona I want a
boy I've been wondering if Corona
like the stock price at Corona has been
tanking who wants to drink a corona now
in this day and this but maybe secretly
it's working because now you're
subconsciously craving Corona cuz
everything in Quran you know the guy who
was doing marketing at Corona his brains
just spinning right now like how can I
do this to our advantage
how can I use it hmm you got any other
big ideas you got the hot ones yeah you
got the hot wings you got the spicy you
have any other I mean you guys you guys
have proven you've got ideas you got
something else yeah maybe you obviously
you're you're afraid to share you don't
want someone to steal it yeah you can't
do that up do you have a list of good
ideas there's like sometimes you have I
think I have a list of dumb ideas you
know and then can we bring Chris in here
yeah Chris come in here come on bring
the Gianna in here he says he's working
back there do come on yeah Chris get it
so it's not being so productive okay get
in here he's not moving
Chris this is good not getting so Chris
Chris Chris Chris Chris Chris
are we all set up here Dan yeah here
have a seat right here no it's been a
come on it's been good what's been tough
what's been tough tell me what's been
tough yeah Michael Jackson
4/6 yeah all right Kelly yeah it's good
stuff that's a good thank you though it
was a really funny episode about it
ya know be like yeah yeah a friend of
mine wrote that maggot joke oh really
I'm a first episode really Larry use
them that yeah I love it out of hanging
out hang out so Chris tell me you are
often not on camera is this your first
time sitting down you've had done
interviews before right yeah yeah yeah
but not of this caliber
yeah thank you very much I'm noticing my
caliber yeah yeah I'm with some local
news you know so the G so this is kind
of where I am but GM so how long have
you been with complex seven-and-a-half
years and how long you been with complex
five or six so were you guys become
friends once you join complex or once or
were you guys friends before just to win
Shawn came to complex and so I came to
start first we feast it was like here's
a computer
mmm and a phone start a brand how did
you how did you become that guy like how
did that - my brother ever disappeared
Epogen yes that moment when Mike food
was becoming more relevant culturally or
like in pop culture and I worked in food
we kind of grew up loving the stuff that
complex although evers ironic in this in
this case nepotism seem to have worked
pretty well hey
they say hire people you know right yeah
also if your boss is your brother it's a
good situation
some people just not listening oh yeah
so what's your brother's position he's
he I he moved on yeah he's moved on
yeah yeah although he was very
supportive of that ones and and the
brand and stuff but yeah it was kind of
fun too I work for my brother Wow
so you so tell me about the rise of the
hot ones brand because you as you were
saying you came in one man one dream one
computer yep oh God and one God which
God Allah or Yahweh
right now it's not decision tough
questions here it's vipers now he's pray
at the altar of Gordon Ramsay correct
answers only okay so tell me about the
yeah write an editorial website you know
we were like busting out 12 blog posts a
day no lady writing no video whatsoever
when we first started making video it
was like you know behind the scenes
chefs in the kitchen it was like not
hopping there were tons of people doing
the same thing so hot ones it was like a
Hail Mary like let's do something
completely different
let's leverage the fact we're in complex
we're like rappers were coming through
the door every day like the beginning of
the show so many rappers were on the
show and Shawn was kind of like this
breakout star of the complex news
universe you are break ups Yarber for
hot ones like if you go back and know
the interviews were excellent before
obviously he's like sean has always in
my mind been one of the great
interviewers of our generation things
Ethan yeah of course yeah like you
recognize download clearly I mean I
don't have like any vision like we just
like Sean said we vibed I pitched it to
him he thought it was funny and we never
knew but it would be it's just a good
example in learning you know some
example of if you just care that much
like keep banging at it keep crafting it
like go to the first episode with Tony
Yayo
it's totally goofy it's just like
throwaway goofy questions I think Sean's
already told you this but we weren't
even gonna have Sean eat Tony Yayo from
g-unit was like dudes this is mad weird
like can you you've gotta get with you
with me because I don't want it to be
this kind of like the right concept and
Sean doing it like imagine Sean forcing
scarlet johansson to eat that
interesting you guys figure that out in
the first episode yeah and thankfully
thankfully big yeah but that's like
that's it so weird is looking at how it
was built that way they're like and
every sort of in every sort of way I
mean I look back on it now and it there
had to be 10mil
coincidences happened and line up the
exact same way that's true to work out
by the way you know where I kind of want
it to be if I got pulled into this room
where GOG was for post Malone you want
me to make a make up I don't need any
more of those I mean thank you for
noticing that that was a good one
he really got me good with that thing so
first we feast was the first video
content you guys produced for four am
sorry hot ones was the first video
content you guys produced not the first
but there was a bunch of stuff but the
first thing they kind of like bubbled up
you're like and were you immediately
like up and set the tone for everything
we've done since you know the burger
show and goichi gang attention right
jouji right like it was the right
articulation of food meets pop culture
like we kind of moved away from being a
food fight and what was the first big
guess where you guys were like oh [ __ ]
yeah I mean when we first started it
wasn't a big view thing you know we used
to joke we're like wow I'm meeting like
some extremely spicy wings for for not
much how many of you know were you guys
getting it first
I don't know 20,000 there's yeah like
you'd like put it up and like maybe the
next day I'd have like 20,000 views but
the first one that ran it up was the key
and peele episode that was that was well
I think we woke up to near a million
views or somewhere like yeah whatever
something's I think that was I had never
something that was like 50x anything
that we'd ever done but the Machine Gun
Kelly episode well I don't think the
views were crazy that was the one I
think that galvanized us
yeah it was just him doing laps like
standing the table being crazy and it
was kind of felt like like something
about this feels special yeah that I
think was probably the first long shoot
like the first 10 wing like concept
banged out shoot yeah or the second one
and I remember like while it was
happening I was like this is insane like
what's going on in this room like it
just seemed like good internet was
happening while it was happening
mm-hmm
and and that's and I was like this is a
show that needs to that needs to happen
I think that to the audience responded
to that where they were like then had an
appetite for whatever we were putting
out probably the last time we did a
gotcha question on Winton yeah about am
dating Amber Rose and he's just like
[ __ ] you well look at you two one
computer one dream yeah and two guys in
ten wings and ten Wayne do you ever eat
the spicy wings do you ever party yeah I
work with our guy Noah at heat inist
and we develop sauces with him and we'll
develop the lineup each season and he's
like 50 sauces that he brings to the
table he's sort of like a guru of the
hot sauce world so I'll do it he'll
Shaun will catch us you know yeah or
walk in it would be like there's opened
up like a bunch of bottles of hot sauce
in this dark room : Shaun it's good
taken a lot of milk
clean a clean bill of health now maybe
it's like cleansing me or something
because the doctor was like very
impressed as my vitals does it get
easier or does it not yeah I think that
um the way that I look at it is I always
know what to expect like a lot of people
may get like when they go on the show
they panic because it's the spiciest
thing they've ever eat the bomb really
you guys do that by design the bomb is
by is this one but not on purpose that
was just accidentally a thing that you
always change but the bomb I always say
is sooo effective because you even if
some of the good would suffice you need
that yeah that one moment that starts
the episode and it does hit everyone
yeah yeah
have you ever once in your career and
don't you lie to me I don't know I love
you right yeah I know it's coming you
and make sure he's honest with me have
you ever put less spicy sauce on your
wings not once for being sick maybe
we're feeling well maybe you had
diarrhea at her you go through it you go
through it I believe you have you been
often accused of that well yeah but I
would make gate was a whole era and it
finally a conspiracy that the wings were
not hot that they didn't have any hot
sauce on them and also that only the
guests had spicy wings and it was like
pervasive because because Sean doesn't
uh he doesn't show but you really have
you can't show every time nobody cares
about Sean sweating yeah exactly
it can't be the show's already you know
just in this dark room with ten sauces
and but I think it can only be self
referential today I have to say though
you know you nibble well not I don't
first off you do know how dare you I
mean you do is I'll try to mirror the
guests but the thing about it you do
okay it's like I can't sit there if like
we're just both like working through
wings together like that's you you want
to keep the red line now you must have a
really because some people can just go
done do you have that I don't have like
a technique or anything I don't have
like a split the book I don't I don't
have any like swag with it or anything
but like in the interview you want to
keep the rhythm of it all right and so
if I was just sitting there like
cleaning every way like staring in each
other's eyes like cleaning wings you
think you could take bigger bites
he has just mirrored the guest yeah I
think it's a nice move he's got like
because there's nothing for Sean to
prove in terms of eating the way out I
would say this even people who have
bowed out Sean's always eaten all ten
he'll continue yep thanks that's even dj
khaled yeah house one of the only people
that bitched out yeah did anyone else
like [ __ ] I like Al he stopped it like
three didn't he like what kind of yeah
were you were you just so disappointed
when he's like no beats it before you
yeah he did oh yeah he does that that's
basically before and yeah no I dad
it was weird as a different time but I
enjoyed that shoot like that to me felt
like it was history we needed that
episode we needed we drew people like
that you know and I love that we do we
do like internally pillows like but me
and Chris love we love that episode so
as far as arbiters of the internet do
you think there should be a DJ Khaled
Redemption yeah I would
Cal it's kind of not that interesting
anymore but do you what about in the
context of like a hot ones round - I
would think so yeah I would watch the
mother-loving but is he interested
because he probably gets in for that I
think it would be great yeah I think
about bringing it to him yeah i think i
DJ is there anyone else who would be on
a Redemption episode the Hall of Shame
which we don't mean like using him
anymore but we do put it up there for
the joke is he's the most extreme
everyone else kind of went for it like
lil yachty had never eaten hot sauce so
his wife would say yeah is harder than
most be most people's road to the end
but he hit the bomb yeah he hit the bomb
is the thing is once you hit the bomb
you just kind of got the worst of it
yeah but you don't know that
psychologically you're like I just hate
that and there's two more yeah I know
like that's the thing that people are
faced with we're gonna Rick eat your
face that was that about
that makes sense and you know I don't
think it's like it's I don't think like
I think cows the only person who truly
needs Redemption yeah right I think
that's the real deal and you guys met
him yeah it was a very sweet man I
really can't say a bad thing
my favorite anecdote from that meeting
is that he catered it with his finger
lickin and he has like a bunch of
housekeepers and servants at his place
and they made him a plate of food with
like a real plate and silverware and
they made him a huge [ __ ] [ __ ]
stacked bro and like a huge thing of red
velvet cake and with like emphasized you
know porcelain plates everywhere and
then everybody else had to use plastic
and paper and I just I just thought it
was funny that he was the only one that
got to use real real because he had his
whole crew there yeah he's got a huge
posse so I've
was kind of picnic-style but he was
Hurst the head of the table with the
real silverware and heating I think
that's somewhat yeah yeah I'm working
away I'm working I do have a beef with
you Sean what and I don't know if I
bought this voice this to you last time
you were here but when we did our
episode you encouraged me Sean to take
nibbles did I and I that's how I
remember it I want to because I wish
that I would have eaten the whole wind
no I didn't feel very challenged by it
but now watching it back I realized that
when you eat the whole wing obviously
it's way more spicy yeah I don't think
and we were taking nibbles and throwing
them away well I don't think that would
have been I think maybe there is
something lost in translation there but
I think so but I still blame but that's
but but I never do the only thing that
I'll do because we there's always like a
little powwow before and so which is
kind of crazy like you know we'll have
like some huge high-profile celebrities
like be like so nervous about the thing
that's going on you know so there is
like sort of a pep talk that I do to try
to calm the nerves you know let them
know I'm eating along with them let them
know that we're interview first that
this is a that this is a disrupt
development in that and that's it you
thought oh it doesn't get [ __ ] weird
over here but I think I like I don't
think I did that Ethan I think well yeah
but but if you were like do I have to
eat the whole thing I probably would
have been like no no you don't have to
eat the whole thing maybe it was
something like that yeah must have been
well I think I said do you eat the whole
thing yeah and you said I just nibble it
and throw it away
oh don't you put those words in my mouth
so we're the guy that's what you said
you guys have a fight creatively like
brothers right yeah and for a long time
you guys have a creative conflicts not
that much to be honest no sometimes
probably a level of Shawn be annoyed at
being asked to do many so many things on
behalf of the brand but right you
represent dream talent yeah
now yeah I think I don't know we're very
simpatico and happened and like kind of
built this thing together so going
through that process in the trenches you
can't fake that
yeah and then I always think like even
if I'm I don't know it's like a
relationship like seriously like there's
sometimes you like alright like Chris
when that one you know what I mean like
yeah yeah if I'm not like a hundred
percent against something or whatever
and that I'm very like Chris is a very
good whisperer to me you know you can
call him like rough seas at nîmes and
like that talked me and era Honda who
was emailing you shout out Sarah Honda
yeah we just worked for her yeah both of
us yeah Sarah what what King me
she was emailing you to get ocean email
like oh another celebrity is to ask you
about me okay you represent the
company's interest I mean you work for
complex no but I'm just trying to
understand where the conflict is so like
maybe Shawn is requested to do a brand
placement or something that he thinks is
a little corny yeah stuff like that or
you know do stuff on social media come
to this event so that we can you let
amusing ourselves with different
partners things like that and you're
like that's a lot too much there's a lot
like every year more and more is going
on right that one and Shawn is of course
youth of faith and you think it's it's
that sometimes too much posting no I
think I'm just being different imes I'm
just like yeah can I just go home after
you know like it's right that but I'm
just being like cranky about it yes
you're it's not because you're you're
the talent god dammit yes hey I'd be a
good luck if you can like get on stage
and do a TED talk at like this all
you're like dude I'm so busy it's like
another to stuff like that so so just
are you technically his boss yeah I
don't think about it that way I mean yes
mmm sounds like
yes Alan who is no I wouldn't say that I
took total collaboration yeah
collaborative effort you're certainly
not his boss no I'm not I'm a lone wolf
like I'm out and like my own gear
contractor in our editor Colin are just
in there yeah hanging out classics
that's the thing yeah I just I'm kind of
like I'm not in any meetings I don't
respond to any emails you know what I
mean I just I'm just kind of like a good
life in the pebble in front like here's
the next guest and then you just start
banging that through and then sit
through the edit and just stay so
attached to the show are you gonna be
involved the show's successful that I
don't have to do that's actually really
good as a talent to just say focus on
yeah you want that tunnel vision exactly
so that's what I'm allowed to do right
now actually into in the tunnel vision
more than I ever have been like since we
started this and it's been awesome
that's really good and I wish because
like all that you're doing all the
brokers and stuff I imagine yeah a lot
of it because that is something that's
really hard to juggle is always to keep
that away from Sean yeah that's a good
deal yeah no he's an executed game show
yeah want to be good that's a smart
producer right there
no he's a good man Sean are you still
gonna be involved in the Edit of the
show yeah I mean I don't know there's
that's the thing is I can't well you
already edited you were you were
involved in the 20 yeah yeah no that's
uh that's different once you end up you
know then that's so much worse that'd be
so much it would be so much I'm so I'm
happy I'm those guys know what they're
doing yeah it's like it's in it's like
it's just a totally different thing and
you base and once you end up with those
big ships involved and stuff then yeah
you know right now sometimes you can
feel that you're in control of the thing
like alright we're in control of the h3
thing like we're on top of it and then
sometimes maybe you feel like it's a big
wave and you're just like a part of it
yeah and so sometimes like you know you
like you can feel like that in hot ones
where it's so big and then you're like
oh like you feel like at one point I
felt on top of it and then now I feel
like I'm
in it person yeah interesting metaphor
yeah yeah alright well Chris were you
involved in the television show EPU yeah
yeah so what is that until the biggest
part was like articulating the DNA of
hot ones and make sure that it carried
through from our show like we're working
with people who have experience making
television which we have no no have we
ever made a game show that said there
was a lot of seating
you know the creative to them and they
were awesome partners but to me the most
important thing was like make sure Shawn
looks good make sure this represents you
know clearly I love this yeah where's my
person make sure Ethan looks good these
guys worked actively every episode to
make me look as bad as possible the
audio doesn't work they are no call me
out when I say wrong [ __ ] there's a
there's a certain level of
professionalization that has happened
here since last I was here absolutely
it's more buttoned up over here oh yeah
how's your love life Chris you are
married how long you been married
well like four years since we had a
wedding but we've been together for 15
or so congratulations that's beautiful
true love
mm-hm kids not yet it's not Hannah
hopefully good yeah how old are you oh
baby spice Lords 36 and and and what's a
good Asian introduced a child to spicy
food in the womb I guess my wife was on
npr's how I built this podcast yesterday
yeah I can dunk on her with h3h3 what
what if you do why she she started her
own company it's called mmm Lafleur it's
a professional women's clothing company
though women should wear mm was slurring
the week
Betty fresh on the weekend yeah got a
collab Wow power couple would you
consider yourself to be a member I don't
like that term or whatever like I would
never want to be on like check out our
apartment you know this video yeah but
you probably have a dope apartment right
it's all right it's wrong spitting I
love it it's problem
it's like it's extremely upper Westside
you know they have oh that's where we
used to live
yeah we'll be there for your roots we
were on Columbus 75th and West End Wow
we were neighbors how many how many
bedrooms not - okay let's take a 10
million dollar spot there you get tired
of flying to LA all the time yeah I
don't even always come I can't make it
have yeah like Sean goes back and forth
what a few moves la what happens then
you ever I'm gonna be sad but you're not
leaving New York I'm not leaving you
know yeah you're nicer well you work
there yeah yeah Rover tan your wife yeah
but like maybe there's a way to just do
it like both you know if you spend so
much time back and forth like that's
kind of the thing that I'm thinking
about now is well want to be feeling
yeah yeah I have to have to drag me off
that damn well mmm this was a real treat
getting you in yeah yeah absolutely and
you guys are a great team I love you
both you've always been close to our
brand your your episode was a big moment
and then it kind of opened the doors for
first we feast to get deeper in the
YouTube space that's very start like
that's how we grew our channel looking
not only on hot ones but all the other
shows youtubers and kind of like built
it out from there that's am I gonna be
gonna be getting a cut of the IP I think
you'd get it before us yeah well it was
it was an honor to the I mean I was
honestly I I'm like I don't do other
people [ __ ] I'm just I think I'm just
now I get that I get that do you think
you want to like control the thing just
stressful yeah that's just stressful
that's the only reason you know I was
gonna ask you guys to be on the burger
show but I'll do the bird
you guys I'll do that it'll be fun I
would love to do the burger show you
know I really want to do it was Bert
right or in Tom Tom Tom did it and I
wash that and I was like man that's
[ __ ] up I should have done it because
it was in and out verse shake shake
shake shack and he said in and outs
better and I'm like and we were like you
know way you're mine so I say this with
peace and love he's got a [ __ ] that up
Tom really [ __ ] that up so that because
as a fan of him in and out I could say
wholeheartedly and emphatically that
that Shake Shack is better like that's
not even a debate am i right
I'm torn now like I was always Shake
Shack and I didn't love in and out but
every time I go I'm kind of I think I
like that classic that my problem with
shakes I cuz it's to raise its head like
that buttered bun it's like edge so it's
like yeah it's to hated very freakin but
like it's good you need a shower after
shape yeah what I'll tell you and I
agree I don't like that they greased
that outside of the bun it's like dude I
didn't I don't need grease on the
outside but at the same time I'll take
grease over a dry bun like dry bread is
Dean I tell Hetty look I would go on I'd
rather not eat then eat dry bread that
Alvin Kyle on who hosts the burger show
is from LA though and he taught me this
trick of you you know those little
banana peppers they have he's night off
the top and then you pour the juice Oh
looper kill everything so if I was on
the burger show what would it look look
what do you what do you guys want to do
what's your without Shake Shack what
other topics can we you know what role
to rights on what Adam
vegetarian stuff stop not there yeah
turn mic off Dan we can we could do
viral burgers we could do international
burgers we could do you know
international world is our oyster mmm
I'm trying to think cuz so for me
sometimes can we include a little mini
candy burger
sure okay best burger in Encino keep it
local Shake Shack but I don't like when
people they get these big fancy burgers
when they put like pineapple and onion
rings and all the barbecue sauce it's
just the more you add the less it
becomes you're gonna go burger show meat
cheese bun that nice that's it simple
sometimes I don't like mrs. stall
and it's like how do you take a bite of
that and it's just not good there's I'm
tell you I'm sometimes not even cheese
well maybe we should eat over-the-top
luxe burgers with you guys and you can
just that's that would be super fun oh
yeah and just attack your philosophy on
burger I like it and we'll probably end
up like in the most simple one that you
can also use ever no no that's true you
never know for me of the perfect burger
high fat content you know you you you
the beauty but it's high fat content
little I'm go ahead and correct me or
Worchester sauce thank you worst you put
a little that in there there you go
you're talking Gordon Ramsay that's it
you go you and then I like the smashy
British people like to do this jag smash
burger
I like the smash technique that's my
favorite and then that's it you call it
a day
put a little mayonnaise - if you're
feeling a little bit weird and wild
right tough to argue no would you guys
need it wait onion or without yeah I
like a grilled onion I like cut through
everything yeah it's just like give me
that raw [ __ ] onion and can do Ron
like it's like sex without the condom
yeah so when are you planning on having
kids you're getting all your 36 you said
time how was your wife same age well
come on
you wanna kid yeah so there you guys
connected with good I wish you uh I'm
happy for you guys
thank thank you we're trying to have
another one will come to your for tips
oh yeah and I was hoping to meet
shredder because I got who's ninety
pounds so oh yeah loves those none know
when they're that much I have a
disparate weight and height we dogs they
get along like there's nothing to fight
about
no really what kind of dog is he he's a
golden retriever Irish sitter makes whoa
what a beautiful exotic animal is a
beautiful dog big boy how long you been
dating Sean that's a good amount of time
yeah I'm good
thinking of moving in well I it's hard
yeah yeah yeah it started these
questions are making you uncomfortable
these question that question are you
don't mind talking about it I know I'm
like kind of an open book but you're an
open book yeah some things that haven't
totally I didn't totally think through
before I came as no surprise there's no
media training well you guys have
accomplished so much I admire you both I
mean all of your achievements talents a
team a dream team credible talent
incredible producer the world is your
oyster and let me tell you in one year
when you've got complex and bite the
balls with that TV show going in season
two or three which it will be you guys
just walk the [ __ ] out hey you say I'm
serious you say listen you need to get
like an insane manager a journal we have
the same agent no we no no no no yeah we
do we do okay but I'm not gonna yeah now
don't turn this on you I'll turn this
idea well I didn't well you can ask me
whatever you want but
but he's he's not getting you any IP cut
I'll say that I mean I wish him well but
you need someone who will like put a
horse head in their bed you know I'm
saying whoa I'm just saying you gotta
good is that you know you guys gonna get
a piece of that action you deserve it
Thank You Ethan now I always appreciate
you know like we've we've been behind
the scenes always we always chat we
always chat so yeah absolutely you know
but people know that but yeah yeah Sean
come on your shark you're bullish man
it's like when we need a contract he's
like should I just write it actually no
Ethan
well you look so good he doesn't see you
guys are a good bad cop bad cop I think
internally ulis backup I'm good cop I'm
like the I'm the good cop until I turned
the bad cop and then I'm the bad cop and
he's the good but outside of
organization I don't [ __ ] around like
I'm talking about our employees and
people within our satellite but when it
comes to closing deals and [ __ ] outside
yeah we that's yeah we're not but you're
us
you know that's okay well if you want to
go if you want me to represent you just
let me know what else what is this is
just say the show when is the show come
out so hot ones the interview show this
Thursday actually oh I'm excited Margot
Robbie we're back yeah premiere the game
show will be February 18th and then run
in tandem
everybody DVR everywhere ER and break
and do TV store and set them all edamame
set it there yeah yeah multiple did you
see the Justin Bieber begging his fans
to to stream his news you know what that
seems to be like a thing I've seen a
couple of those I've never seen anyone
out right like posts on their on their
platform hey guys set it to repeat all
night
yeah yeah or like put it on mute or
whatever I was like wow Justin data like
we always talk about that type of stuff
or when they they try to get like break
and Instagram likes record or something
ya know the notion that the audience
would be interested in helping them and
they are sometime yeah I guess that's a
new generation they are crazy to me I
like your jacket
I also know I said ganya and it's
beautiful yeah you're a bit of a are you
a bit of a know once a height piece for
Europe you appreciate if I have a like
trickle down good sneakers and stuff
because my brother has always been in
that world so I noticed you were rocking
I asked Sean on dm's because I saw you
were in this I thought it was yeah that
got mixed reviews what did you think
about it I liked it
I mean sweatpants with that based on
quality or apparent appearance too
garish
some some say where'd you get that it's
fire yeah so you know well I know thank
you I know but you can as Sean said get
the whole sweat suit yeah same pattern I
was too slow on that oh you tried to get
this wetsuit
yeah I actually really like no I'm not
wearing that what I wear them all yeah
me too every one of my faves yeah but
they're kind of snobbish I they told the
story on Instagram to like this cotton
was was made by just one try a Malayan
monks [ __ ] yeah it was made in China
yeah okay like how long we've been going
down you guys right about a hour 45 hell
out 45 you guys going short pod in
today's world yeah we got to go at least
five hours yeah we're trying to get
pregnant
yeah thanks we're gonna find out in a
couple of days if we were successful
yeah we gave it a good effort how many
kids you want to I think just to showed
you got when you are you guys doing like
are you guys like
timing the fertility and all that yeah
we've been through a long journey with
it really yeah
it takes a while tell me about it you
know I mean you grow up thinking it's
very easy and it's not there's a lot
that goes into it don't talk about yeah
I should because I just like two years
yeah it took us two years and by the way
how is there billions of people in the
world where it's so hard for us to have
kids I guess I think the thing is when
you're 18 and she's 18 then you know if
you breathe on or she gets pregnant but
as we get older because in the today we
take our time we got careers we're doing
[ __ ] we want to actually race this kid
in a good environment then all the
sudden you know you're shooting I'm
shooting sawdust basically but we got
lucky one time what so what's the what
tell me about the process you don't have
to do if you're uncomfortable I just you
said I just don't want to you know it is
private descent yeah you know it is very
private it's very I would be super
impressed if my wife got to this point
in a podcast like I kind of wanted to
like put it there just as a test and
she'd be like hey I heard this honey but
I'm gonna leave it there well that's
okay I understand
well just so you know it took us two
years we went to fertility doctors we
did the whole thing we counted my I
jerked off into a little cup mm-hmm I'm
sure you've done that that's just weird
right you I went I went into this booth
this is wild
this whole world okay I'm fast I go to a
booth and then I actually took pictures
for the podcast go so where there's a
chair and paper right and I was like I'm
not sitting in that chair this is all
over the generations yeah on the wall
there was cheese stains or maybe there's
water stains what I mean who's not a
running stain and then so then they have
like - oh it was in LA just reputable
and then they've got they've got like a
VCR bro
and hang in VCR or maybe DVD but at this
point what's the difference in that the
technology right it's like the same
thing and then they've got headphones
that you have to I'm like I'm not
touching anything there they expect you
to put on headphones like I don't need
that much help I've got my smartphone
and they had like an empty bottle of
Lube like it was used to the room Oh
booth oh it's a jerk-off bills just
enough space for our chair and a TV to
the walls go to the ceiling or like ifs
yeah yes yes that would but then so you
walk out with a cup of semen I then
there wasn't anyone there to greet me to
tell me what to do like you would expect
so I'm walking around with a cup of
semen for minutes looking for somebody
for minutes on end what felt like an
eternity and walk around the cup of
semen being like you know oh they make
you write down the exact time you each a
culated two and second and like to the
minute you know was that similar to yeah
I understand it is private but I wish
you luck and thank you I wish you all
the best at the end it just happened
when we decided to like not focus on it
right that's true up all months yeah
that's true not even think about it yeah
and then it happened but your sister did
the IVF yeah yeah twice it's the whole
thing man you gotta get in the lab now
you have kids so you guys don't thought
I mean you know don't want to read too
much into it clearly you don't want to
talk about it so I'm just really calling
in about it but I enjoyed the your story
oh and they give you like a porno mag
and the I swear to god it's all sticky
pages but you're right in the look at
the notion of like in the age of the
smartphone there's a penthouse from
1980s there's something baby mag I'm
like is it pretty funny yeah I guess not
everyone in there has a smartphone may I
felt like people just like paid you know
five bucks to go and jerk off in there
like at
adult stores there's booths where you
can jerk off apparently it felt like
that
it's like naughty no not naughty likes
like aids II yeah
hepatitis yeah okay sticky coronavirus
yeah corona what are you guys into what
do you do talk to me what do I do
so we have ended this already started
ela should we end this I thought did you
guys not have a Oh cuz I thought someone
had yeah they said but I think the thing
thinking I think we have we have
something a little bit but whatever I
was getting I'm for anyways yeah you got
your you're doing late-night shows hot
ones in the late night yeah rubbing
shoulders with the powerful and and
elites okay whose star struck you the
most but probably a weird answer but uh
you know I grew up I think we've even
talked about this but I was such a love
line kid growing up and Adam Carolla was
like really or you know I really like a
hero of mine growing you know I I listen
to I was obsessive about it and it's
probably what kind of pushed me into
doing this sort of thing more than
anything else and so having him on the
show was like such a thing and then I
went to the comedy store like last week
and I think I was over-served and he was
there and I like kind of ran up on him
was I was like do it's cuz oh man like I
love you so much like you don't
understand I love you so much so that's
maybe like not that you know like but
that was the thing that was one of the
more surreal sort of sitting across more
surreal sort of where you are where this
is gone mmm kind of like from you know
when it started it felt very full circle
or something like that to me and then
Chris's probably Alexa Chung for similar
reasons yeah when we had her on early on
is because it was just it felt very full
circle
who's Alexa Chung I didn't see that
episode me look it up he used to have
he's a
British model and host and she had this
super funny show called pop world you
know in England and I just loved it and
she would do these super cheeky
interviews that were kind of just making
fun of the celebrities but like very
sarcastic and this is the girl from that
fashion show enough yeah yeah just got
so weird
he is hilarious I literally just idea
for hot ones was how to take a show like
that and a cheekiness like that if you
line it with wings so it was kind of an
inspiration from the show for the show
coming on the show it's very yeah yeah
so it's like kind of any other like my
mom's British and I grew up with all
this British comedy so Ricky Gervais
wrestle Brandon what when those people
come on here the ones where hi I'm so
jealous of those ones I won't Ricky
Gervais and Russell is a Ricky would
Ricky be an awesome dude how do I get
Ricky's like yeah he how'd you get Ricky
well that was funny remember something
he wouldn't do right but one of the nice
guests yeah - yeah after we wrapped and
you know he only made it to 8 and then
tapped out he was so apologetic like we
got read you're raising you're so funny
and I love Ricky but that was he's very
kind
that was one of our favorite like eras
ever doing the show because it was at
such a crossroads for us and what's this
going to be and we are very
opportunistic we're we're like okay if
we have an opportunity to shoot with
somebody we just popped the thing up
wherever whenever wherever and what
happened did we get who do we land with
a key Gervase crazy we did a London trip
yeah I didn't really have much of a
budget back then so it was sort of like
if we're gonna go to London we have to
line up all of these videos we did Ricky
Gervais Russell Brand and the DJ who I
think is funny called Charlie sloth and
then we also shot a video with the
chicken connoisseur who is sort of viral
right I don't remember the Jason cage
was reviewing fried chicken BOTS in
London so we went out and shot that we
shot a burger video and then big
Shawn in the wild that was only three
days so we were we had nothing we had
nothing so like to make it going to get
where we weren't just flushing the
budget down the toilet we had to just
from from wait from from noon to night
shoot you know we had to just make that
stuff happen and we would just be up you
know writing these like writing the show
until like 2:30 3:00 a.m. then like wake
up its sig's and then just try to
execute it remember that that was that
but it lagged and jet-lagged running on
bombs but that was very galvanizing yeah
that really brought us together as a
team that is a good thing about your
guys's set I mean I would you could
anywhere yeah but yeah it everywhere
almost made the show despite it not
being on purpose because it's my work if
we had to have everyone come to New York
right yeah and yeah with names like that
you got it how often do you guys go to
your guests
half of them really maybe more well they
got six or we will have by the end of
this week zero of which have been in New
York that is awesome
yeah because they all feel like they
came to you which makes almost the show
feel even more prestigious but when you
get an a-list celebrity who's interested
and you [ __ ] fly to them you just
make it happen yeah - because we're so
prolific
you know the show hasn't been going on
that long and we're in our 11th season
hundreds of episodes out and to keep
that going where you're putting out you
know between like 30 and 45 it's a lot
of interviews a year it's just an -
because we take our time in the
post-production to like deliver this
sort of like polish experience to the
viewer but it's you just have to win
like the names you have to just turn
burn and then you're committing all that
time to this thing so it's like it's
like a big cruise ship that also has to
turn on a dime on time yeah how many
people would it take to set up this set
like if you if you're flying to someone
it's a pretty small crowd like three to
four people including Sean will fly out
and then you know the cruise six people
black background boom boom boom yeah
bless
how do you get wings when you're on the
road you get good wings on the road
yeah so we have like the vegan wings
that we've been using locally I think
it's bulan or in LA and that came
because like Natalie Portman those are
her vegan which she's like oh I want
these blonde tianjin wings what about in
UK you go to Ricky Gervais how do you
get for knowing but those were like so
for Ricky Gervais he had vegan wings and
then they have some vegetarian right
yeah and then he was I'm just better
than anyone I've ever had about life or
real if we go to a new city we'll have
to do research and and you know test a
bunch of stuff before we give it to
people so do you guys ever do interviews
where someone's like on set like a
a-list celeb and you've got to go set up
a makeshift studio in an unusual place
those common is that junket so you know
right thankfully more publicists and
studios know the show now so they
basically booked it at the end but
because they can't like them do five
other interviews the risk is in the
first chunk it's always run late so then
like the time gets compressed and you
know they've been doing press all day so
they're tired but the hot sauce tends to
bring people's energy so how do these
junkets work I've always wondered is it
like there's one place in LA where all
these people who are gonna interview
them yeah they're above like go-to spots
for the most part which will often be in
hotels but you know and yeah era that
we're in there's there's so much more
stuff like hot ones like you know the
lie detector test so everyone's kind of
getting their own rooms and popping up
their little games know that and stuff
the actor comes they just jump room to
room yes like they're in a little bit of
a circuit I always feel like we're sort
of removed someplace like we might be in
a suite unlike the third floor pop and
that thing up and then and then somebody
else is doing the circuit downstairs and
then we'll get like though all right 15
minutes like lock it all in sort of the
situation and then we just Andy so you
you think people are starting to kind of
in popular media and other interviewers
take notice of what's going on with the
hot ones phenoms yeah it's not like a
week over week sort of seems to get what
do you see out there like that that
closely resembles what you guys are
doing
you feel like anyone's like stray trip
there's a million Street and some of
them are huge like there is really big
Russian one there's big South American
ones and you know sometimes we'll get in
touch with them if they're cool and they
kind of mention us you know it's not
like we want no one to be able to do
this but there are some people have just
stolen the comment do they steal the
name - they'll they'll steal like the
exact set up watch the graphics you know
wow I guess when you're in Russia no
call it something different cuz it's a
Russian but yeah yeah what about in
America well I think yeah I mean
probably stuff gets tweeted at me all
the time
I've lost the like I used to get when we
first started do you remember there was
like this one weekend where like it was
like Fox Sports australia launch
something and BBC launched something but
we were just so in our infancy that
people the reason that I even learned
about the Fox Australia thing is because
somebody tweeted at me about ripping off
like Fox Sports Australia and I was like
what the hell you and then I like looked
it up and I was like oh this is the
exact same show so at that point you
know because we felt you know we felt so
small in that that we had to beat our
chest and then kind of weaponize
whatever cult following that we had to
stomp out we shut it down
that was bubbling up but at this point
I've I've totally lost the you guys want
about well I feel like it's not like
we're it's not like because now you're
not gonna be accused of you stole you
want yeah it was sort of like Oh someone
could overtake us with a bigger budget
and has monsters in some water bag and I
we really don't think that we're trying
to get
as one yeah Sarla johansson yeah now I
think it's just it's just out I or it's
not like anybody's discovering something
new and thinking that's the thing you
know I think that at this point people
have either heard of job offers Sean uh
yeah I mean I don't have to you know
like I could I could I could have
pivoted away from doing this but I just
but to me it's uh it's everything I've
ever wanted and then now the team that I
work with like you know we talked about
Sarah Honda and obviously Chris is here
but it's bigger than that like everybody
who's connected to this show now it's it
feels so SEAL Team six or something you
know it just feels like I wouldn't want
to do this with anyone else you have a
show that's yours that you know it's
just me and Chris not just me and Chris
but like creatively whatever we want to
do we can do nobody's standing in the
way of whatever vision we have for the
show so in a weird way it's everything
that I've ever wanted and then so you
stay so dome into it right and so you
see and I'd love it still so I I
couldn't walk away from it because I
still feel like we have work to do there
and you know I haven't totally sawed
through exactly how we want to see
through like I haven't walked away from
an interview yet and been like alright
I'm at peace with it like I'm ready to
do the next thing I think that comes at
some point and it could have come
already if I wanted to but I don't
I I'm committed to it and I love it more
than I ever have right now I actually
think that the year that we just had was
the most proud I've ever been of no
really cool in the years that we've been
doing it and grass so and if Shawn
leaves one day what are you getting he's
lost
what's happened now is going with me
like whatever he's speaking for you he
knows he knows it whatever whatever I do
from here now it's gonna be bunk what
you quit Jerry Maguire I don't know I
have to review the facts a little bit I
I noticed that Sean was speaking up for
you I mean we
again like we've done it from the
beginning you guys ever see I'm so hard
to even imagine that okay let's say
Shawn dies yeah that that's easier you
look for new I do I'm moving to the
country with Sean Sean get Citroen virus
what do you do how long do yeah that's a
good question good more do you think I
would be a good host perhaps yeah thank
you the audience likes you thank you
very much we've checked on sleep check
the tubular data and the h3h3 audience
first we feast audience overlap it's
nuts
oh really yeah it's awesome what are the
challenge do you overlap was Philly d is
a big one he wouldn't be a bone Appetit
obviously if Shawn died you wouldn't
want Philly do we turn it turn it into a
reality show where they're all competing
yeah yeah you would probably want I
would probably be the natural fit if
Shawn had an untimely death we've
actually had some talks like sometimes
we joke around and think about oh really
what were some names that came up but I
do it is friends of the branly yeah Bert
Kreischer like Bert would be a good
brand time would be good yeah Tom would
be good but you know sometimes the late
night shows have guest hosts yeah all
right
like if Shawn ever wants to take six
months off that could be fun wow that's
true would you ever take six months off
the show that's so long aren't you
scared now at this point because you
know are you scared that it often are
you are you in there have CDs often
there'd have to be some measure of fear
about taking six months off and letting
someone else yeah and then yeah I mean
like yeah if you're a quarterback of a
team even if things are going good you
don't ascend the bench and let somebody
else you don't want to grow a beer
exactly so like there's definitely that
but who could replace the great Shawn of
it I don't know it's awesome replaceable
replaceable ethan klein that yeah that's
Bert would be funny but he's just he's a
drunk but
I would say unreliable I would say if do
you want the keys do you even want the
keys you know it's one of those yes do I
want think this show is eaten scorching
out chicken wings and spending half your
life on a plane you know that being
complained I think theoretically I would
a rare combination of talents to be
great at interviewing and be able to eat
super spicy wings you know it's not a
good job yeah I'm just saying Burke
clashes are drunk he's unreliable Tom
Segura he's got he's got place got like
kids and he's always touring I mean
that's a mess I'm here I'm in LA it's
where you guys shoot most of them I
think we just heart pivot and Mario
Lopez Brian's secret you ruin the show
immediately we just go that Ryan
Seacrest would be an interesting guest
um Nicki would be yeah and you know what
even though I don't like it and it's so
long he's got it he's got good stories
to tell yeah I don't like him you know I
would watch it I mean I've never met him
or worked with him or whatever but you
think he'd be an interesting guy I think
you would Thanks but he's so the thing
is he's so he's so good he's such a
showpiece that I don't I'm not
necessarily sure let's guard maybe if
you if you scratch the surface you're
the man I don't know what's you don't
know it's underneath that's true
darkness and I sure darkness I do like
the host V host interviews onra you know
like when we have people who host stuff
like on hot ones like they'll like to
have a certain rhythm and I have Stan
and I do enjoy the experience of those
types of interview interesting you know
would be the this will never happen but
Howard Stern right that would never had
him and let him in you later man but
this guy does guys that'll never happen
but you know I said that about Bobby Jon
I said why the [ __ ] would Papa John ever
come on my podcast do you have yeah but
John hasn't even done like media do you
understand this is the pop and
coming here they do that I mean this is
unbelievable yeah how do you have a date
on when he's sitting in here
yes it's Monday whoa this Monday what
are you gonna do to prepare for it
heat Pizza the only way yeah I've got a
million question I've got there's so
much to talk about did he know about you
before I think recently my theory was
that he signed up with a publicist who
is actually smart and she knows of me
and sees the opportunity a lot probably
be like ah you don't want to get
involved or but this the genius and it's
one with a vision right that's exactly
right
all right well it's been over two hours
I mean I don't know I feel privileged I
feel blessed I feel honored
what more is there to say than that
right we've set it off this show can't
wait for the show I can't wait for the
new episode what do you think of Vogue's
sixties what is that hate it [ __ ]
hate it and let me tell you want yeah
you'll probably have the same reason
your shows so much better it's so fake
yeah yeah they try to no we've seem like
it's so genuine yeah and it's so [ __ ]
fake I hate it
the reason I bring it up is because I
know Marga Margot Robbie did one she
just did one all right least washed one
and it's like I don't know why people
like that show I find it offensive we've
yeah I don't love that after we watch
them all yeah it's a good information
dump yeah like you can just choose the
topics people always love seeing rich
people's houses that's a lot of time to
save in their house right because they
don't want to show their they say that
about like cribs and stuff that they
were all just like rented or whatever
yeah like I you know that Redman who
knows James Corden and Justin Bieber
getting towed in that car I can't you
know what's real and what's fake you
know do you see that no no
it seems important that's the same right
yep he he's not around it's on like a
total they're telling it oh my god
mother and I wasn't bothered by that
because it's not a show about driving
that you're right right if it was but
it's meeting the Cardinal you don't
think about bothered because your
producer and you understand gistic I've
lost my soul that's true
you just feel fold a little bit as a
viewer that's it that's true
I thought he was driving it's me yeah
well you're just yeah too close to like
how the sausage is made or yeah I don't
remember I I didn't like when James
Corden did this whole thing about what
was it Bill Maher he said Bill Maher was
fat shaming people well never I've a
glee remember that yeah yeah he had a
really funny show in England and it's
been really he's for he at you do you
desert and resentment among the English
people when they when talent leave and
just go do American [ __ ] ah you got John
Oliver you've got outrage Gordon I feel
like they're confident in their their uh
shows and have enough talent yet there's
a lot of talent yeah maybe they don't
maybe seem like [ __ ] and super funny GBC
is those guys are yeah me what about
Louis Theroux
okay great he's one of my dream guests
he's awesome who's here number one like
from the audience who's your number one
like the thing that gets shouted hapa
John Pappajohn but after Papa John
people are always always requesting Joji
posts Malone it's like we've already you
know who other than them Dan you guys
would know what do you guys see in the
comments no I mean you just listed off a
lot of our latest episodes have just
been about like kind of like no guest so
I don't know its relevance yeah it's
funny people get so angry at me
I get so much hate online these days but
I'm learned to accept that you don't get
hate to your love but you're universally
loved well I think you see I think
everybody sees their own what do people
say about you I mean I don't know like
to me it's the way that I've Oh Eric
Andre's another big one yeah you'd be
great the way that classic how many got
your camera um I guess you know you have
to figure out how to manage all that
because it's so loud all the time you
know especially like when you're just
you're always making something and
you're always putting it out and then
you're caught in that feedback loop 24/7
and and listen I'm so I'm sensitive like
I'll see ya like it could be ten nice
things the one oh yeah the thing that
I'll remember and that'll stick with me
so a while ago I just got into the habit
of like just making the thing and then
putting it out and then just making the
other thing and then putting it out
because like if you ever feel like you
have some sort of ownership over that
thing it doesn't matter however it's
taken or whatever and I was yeah I was
putting myself and you know I was
sending my brain and in a spiral so I
think that uh to me it's just you know
you make the thing you put it out in the
world and then the audience can do
whatever they want with it but while
that's happening I've I've separated
from it yeah I just make the next thing
yeah once I got into that it really
helped me a lot what were the comments
that bother you
I don't know I guess like I don't know
I'm trying to think is that I haven't
done a good job of just sort of blocking
this whole thing out but it's almost
just like the it's just the negativity
again yeah or it's just the even it
doesn't even have to be me in the
crosshairs of it like it could be our
guest like sometimes you'll like look
back at the Internet as like a mirror
and didn't it'll like just kind of break
your heart on on you know we have this I
know
yeah with each other or whatever in like
the way but then too is I don't need to
have like such a heavy heart because I
don't need to like be you know I don't
need to have a job on the Internet
where I'm making something on the
Internet and then be on the internet all
the time like you can just kind of shut
it off and go about your life and and
have a healthier relationship with it
absolutely you have so you have to fit I
think for every person they're different
but there's probably a thing where all
right you start to make a thing it
starts getting attention you're
interested in what people are saying
about it and it doesn't make sense to
pay attention to it because the audience
can serve is a is a focus group kind of
for whatever you're making and you can
help it can help you shape the show in a
lot of ways but then once it gets to
once it's achieved a certain thing or
once it breaks containment on something
it's not just your fans talking about it
anymore now it's like a big zeitgeist
thing that's kind of consumed by like so
many people and then that's kind of
feeling like you can feel like you're
connected to and with your audience at
some point and then it breaks out to a
thing where you're like wow like now I'm
just in a room getting like shouted at
from every direction that's exactly like
pushed in and pushed and pulled in like
10 million different directions yeah and
then it's like alright are you gonna
just try to surf those waves and
whatever I think that leads you to like
a really negative place it did for me
we're just really loud and heavy all the
time and so like you didn't want I don't
want to look at my phone I didn't want
to like open it up like you text
messages I'd get like a little like good
like you just want to block it out
entirely so as a way to just cope with
all of that in a different way I just it
was like you know what it doesn't matter
like nothing changes about the process
of making the thing and putting it out
like the only thing that's changing is
the the degree to which I care about the
noise surrounding it and you can just
mute it like you can't just shut it off
so I've been doing that that's probably
that's great in a lot of ways why we had
the year that we had that's great just
being able to I genuinely think that
everyone in a position that that we're
in has to either come to a point where
they learn to to let's say transcend
that and to live like along with it or
it destroys you right it's like you have
to if there's no two ways about it
do you ever get
if comments ever get to you I mean
you're not on camera but like obviously
it's you're sure about the show and the
brand for sure yeah you know and I think
to Sean's point we're protective of the
guests like it is right you don't sort
of upsetting when yeah everyone just
goes off on a guest who's yeah come and
eaten spicy yeah you don't want to be a
Basset in and research and obviously we
wanted them to be on the show and then
sometimes because hot ones is so
outsized in its you know how big it's
grown you know we're proud of our other
shows too of course there's that
audience of get this show the hell out
of here we're only here for hot ones and
Sean and I talk about this all the time
it's like all of this is free you know
you do all this for you to watch it and
there's eight trillion other options
think okay watch this video like I think
we're living in such a such a great age
of entertainment where there's so much
competition for eyeballs and then the
the cost of it it's so low compared to
you know when I was I'll date myself
here but I remember you know being like
in fourth grade going to Sam Goody
buying like two CDs a pack of Lemonheads
and some double-a batteries for my CD
player and that [ __ ] would be like 54
bucks right you know what I mean now you
can get like Spotify Apple music and
title for an entire month of like the
entire library like at the convenience
of a phone yeah for less than that you
know what you used to get like 30 songs
for and then same now whether it's like
the the streaming wars or cable or the
internet or YouTube and like YouTube I
feel like is the most transparent of it
all because there's like that
there's the thumb there's like the thing
like you don't you don't have to click
the thing and whatever you want to do
with your eyeballs and ears it's like
totally up to you like you can curate
everything you watch and what you're in
to your direct tastes and interests if
you wanted to in a way that's pretty
cost effective but then still it seems
like people rather be miserable I mean
that in a place they don't even need to
be the the the actual like path to
leaving that comets interesting because
they got a notification they clicked on
the notification they watch the video
they weren't interested in the big
in with and then they left the common I
mean that's a lot okay actually the
ricky gervais has a good thing about
this which I'll butcher but he he was
pointing out the steps it takes to hate
on someone and it's like going up to
their door knocking yeah they open it up
and you go [ __ ] you I don't like yeah
and then I think it then it's just like
in such volume mmm-hmm that eventually
it kind of cracks you a little bit I do
like you know 1% of 50 million it's a
lot of [ __ ] people
yeah right exactly I'm thing I find
funny is that because Sean's the face of
it all he also gets this kind of hot
sauce community Oh like acting like the
Guru of hot sauce and a bottle broke
when it was shipped to me can you get me
a refund and hit you up that's right up
tidal wave of the law services question
Greece people you know they'll just
they'll be like hey dude it's my buddy's
bachelor party like it would be so sweet
like if you could just like come out and
we get that all the time you know like
yeah we're people yeah we're and I'll
get like 50 of those a day when I
appreciate it you know like I do I do
like you know but then you're like
you're like wow like you know you just
feel like you get like spread so thin or
whatever just being tugged at and I'm
gonna it's sweet that they think of you
yet accessible but they also it's like
they really think you don't have [ __ ]
you know just like I just shoot your
shot thing or whatever but uh yeah
always like it is I get a lot of
birthday anniversary and Vice wedding
invites what is the people who see you
in the wild
what is h3h3 superfan look like couples
really a lot it's almost like I would
say 50% the dude yes we should
sweethearts yeah college age we love
that you know it's always the bar back
the bouncer yes security people who are
and that we kind of thought that was
like oh this is real like all the divert
hands we want yeah that's awesome at
least early on like TSA always cracks
jokes deshaun I love that stuff yeah all
that you down for wings yeah Oh for real
yeah they'll do that even like last time
out of song last time I went through lax
the guys there they were like oh you
have any sauces like that sounds like no
you guys don't let me take that [ __ ]
through yeah and then they're like
alright hey February you mean
you ever get hooked up like oh yeah heat
treatment what's your favorite VIP
treatment well that's what's good about
like being like very back of house oh
yeah that's good like if you go to a
club and somebody recognizes you or
whatever yeah shout out like what like
what happens they'll let you in the door
they'll give you free drinks what
happens at the club yeah you get out you
know whatever you could just be some
jerk off in the line you know like
whatever but if they know the show then
you're in then when you were dating were
you getting recognized I mean you're
dating now but like whenever
relationship first started or did you
ever like walk around with her do
something I get recognized yeah you
guess gotta be baller right yeah yeah
exactly yeah exactly
but um it does it does help and then
YouTube makes you like so accessible so
it's people hey you ever get recognized
yeah
but you know whatever if you go to a
hotel like we're big shout out a sleek
at the Mondrian because it's like you
know like if they recognize you then
you're oh here's a full lounger in ears
like the top you know what I mean like
being if they know you from the show
that's the best that's that's where you
yeah next level the best my favorite
hookup was like we were at like someone
let us cut in line and Disneyland yeah
yeah that's actually the guy who was
working the ride goes to the front
that was a while it's pretty good
I need to have we we don't get good
hookups to be fair we don't out and
about or yeah but I think that's the
thing like if somebody knows you from
the show like the whole world is a place
where like yeah like people could do you
a solid if they wanted and then if they
like your show they looks then for you
it's you know it's solid it's like you
he gets peripheral yeah you get trickle
down you get trickle down but it's fun
rolling around Sean you've been getting
you actually like you feel like you live
like your own success vicariously
through Sean yeah yeah also you know as
we've mentioned I shouldn't be on camera
so thanks for this but you know that's
what I love about having someone like
Sean and then we worked so hard on the
interview and I love the part of
interview but wouldn't be a good
interviewer so there's a vicarious
thrill of like yeah building it out with
Sean and him executing it so never would
you ever watched on and everyone be like
honestly that rarely happens I mean like
Sean knows when to cut things off and
I'm like a little wedded to things once
we've worked on it but you know he
always makes the right decisions but I'm
like I wish we had like asked that I
wanted to hear what they said about it
but he's editing in his head and he
knows and he's reading the celebrity the
genius yeah
one thing once in a while Sean will be
hungover that's always fun but how do
you get more conversational but well
we're too prolific we we Craig yeah you
know what I mean you don't have a moment
you're shooting every day you get upset
when he shows up not and it's never you
never been yeah like that's what we'll
be drinking together no it's just it's
just a there's a vibe that probably only
I noticed it's a little it's nice having
the ability to edit though well yeah and
it's very but it's but it is kind of a
bad habit when you're kind of doing it
live you know we're I'm always caught in
between
you know because you do have there's so
much nonverbal vibe stuff that goes on
and making sure that you know we always
pride ourselves on having like the least
comfortable most comfortable interview
so there's always so much that you're
trying to take care of and then you're
always roadmapping in your brain like
where we try to keep like each wing like
its own little ecosystem but it's like
sort of a choose-your-own-adventure
while it's happening
so you're kind of thinking about that
and that's but now I always am like kind
of like in like I'm having the show go
ahead in your in your mind each wing
represents a new topic
yeah so in in this or this is this is a
fun thing for us to dive into because
it's like so a nerdy part of hot ones
but you know to ask you know maybe this
is a bizarre claim to make on a podcast
where we're gonna go our we're goin
hours on end but you know it's it's
tough to ask for 25 Internet minutes
from anybody you know for for these
types of people and yes yeah you know
it's like people like you for example
you obviously that's my song you just go
yeah but asking of asking like 25
minutes in internet time it's such a
commitment yeah for people and so to us
we were like alright well we don't want
it to be to feel like one 25 minute
interview what we want to do is just
break it off into these acts where like
each wing is its own topic or thing or
something that has an arc in its own
like on its own and the the show is is
sort of naturally has that because it's
like alright so we start by eating the
wing like maybe there's a reaction maybe
there's a non-sequitur maybe it goes
into the question then you then you have
you know a million different ways that I
can go different directions within that
wing whether it's like a different topic
whether they're just so smoked out by
spiciness that they can't get over it we
have to have this reaction and then it
has some sort of way that it lands
either with like a mic drop
statement or like something funny or
like a reaction to the sauce or like
something that foreshadows what's going
to happen later on in the episode so we
lay it out that way
so that people have the experience of
just watching like 12 relatively fast
videos stacked on top of each other
with a through-line that goes like from
the beginning to the end but that's why
we're always kind of like keeping you on
it it's like a show were you like I'm
only gonna watch one episode
oh wait I'm hooked so I'm like on to the
next thing we try to link the wings that
way and then that's why you have like
you know some of the best episodes
whether it's Terry Crews or there's
certain episodes where they they touch
so many different things in their career
in their life where each wing is like
peeling off a layer of who they are is a
multi-hyphenate entertainer or whatever
that way we're covering all that ground
in a way that the viewers like link to
it and sticking with it and engaged with
it and probably doesn't even realize
what's hooking them along mmm but we
think about that and talk about that and
care about that I don't think I've ever
laid that out that's very DNA but that
makes a lot of sense you know cause
there's a certain rhythm yeah
tear geysers show that that is very
attractive I think Shawn being in the
weeds of the Edit and the music and
everything to the next level you know
just having the whole DNA kind of be
articulated in this clear way yeah I
know what you guys are a power couple no
it is weird I mean I could gush over him
but it is like creatively like very
jinyang like I'm so grateful that
somehow me and I'm we're all grateful
are you guys you guys consider each
other best friends yeah in a way that
gets different you know I have best
friends and it's like the same like it's
six to eight people I grew up with I
like still like my best friends but then
the relationship that I have with it is
different you know you ever get like now
that you've kind of come up to a new
level of success and notoriety do you
feel any strain with any of your former
former friends no nobody nothing no no
family friends like nobody gives a [ __ ]
no but
like nobody's nobody's gasps and me
nobody feels like slight about anything
like it's all just the same all exactly
the same I haven't had anything weird
mm-hmm good for you yeah not yet
now you get to that season three of the
show yeah yeah my friends are the same
they're just the same way you know
they're supportive whatever but they're
not like no you know no special
treatment nothing got like awkward I
know yeah nobody's asked him for money
or anything it's like nothing's weird it
took about 150 episodes for my mom to
not be embarrassed to talk about the
show he's a superfan but my mom was has
the same idea where the hot ones beanie
I'm like embarrassed so obviously at the
beginning of the show she didn't know
any of those people and you know it's
people know it's lame yeah yeah and now
she's rocking the market now she's
riding hard on the merger yeah my mom
basically we moved here from Israel our
channel was already doing like pretty
well and then my mom was still trying to
get me to quit and move to Vegas to
become a teacher
after we I was already making more money
than I would as a teacher so went out
but now they wrote the merch now they
rock them yeah yeah that's nice you know
it was one of those sympathize to be
like hey Dad like here's my no-show et
wings with like Machine Gun Kelly or
whatever yeah you know and he'd be like
but I think at work your dad was not my
dad it started off with him almost
trying to forbid us from ever making a
video I got it from the family yeah yeah
yeah yeah I made a video parody of shake
that ass called shake that dick somatic
video because why not right yeah yeah
yeah you know equal opportunity so he
was like you guys don't I ever make
videos again he's not allowed he's
old-school
but it went from that to like him
telling him telling to his friends about
what we do and stuff like that so it was
actually yeah her dad passed recently
somewhat recently a year ago and we
found out or you found out through his
family because they unfollowed each
other on Facebook because I've lost him
on Facebook because that was how I found
the videos like I can't be worried about
him saying what I do so we found out
after he passed that he was sharing all
of our content on Facebook which was a
very in short as long as you make money
like the Ricky Gervais sup is like he
was like whoa yeah like our uncle bear
whatever and he's like I am no guy yeah
you know then they have like a different
perspective all of a sudden oh yeah but
you can't blame him never at first being
like what my parents were fairly
supportive yeah they were they were my
mom just annoying but whose isn't
shout-out to my mom she probably didn't
make it this far
nobody did we killed at this left this
deep were about two and a half hours
over ain't bad that we joked that nobody
listens this deep so this is when the
conversation gets loose so if you guys
have anything racist you want to say any
talking points white supremacy or no
okay
guys the power couple Sean Evans and
Chris Schoenberger Sean burger that's a
Jew right then you're doing it over
there aside yeah damn how fabric does
your lineage go I'm Jewish by the way in
case you think I'm like you read so
deeply but my dad side of family is uh
you know oh your mom's not is going
she's yeah she's
British no so you're not good you're not
you're not your pedigree is not there
yeah I took a the stiff upper lip of a
bridge I took a 20 is for you for your
enjoyment
I took a 23andme thing and I'm 99.7%
European Jew wow I'm just like her I'm
Jesus your bread yeah I have a lot of
neurological problems on my clothes CD
after rest syndrome so it's good that
you're missing yeah it's good you don't
want to go fold bread ever you see those
pugs that came and breathe pug dogs yeah
yeah that's what G that's what my family
with that inbred and purebred that know
I have such low life expectancy zijn
it's sad faces you know the Bulldogs
thank you for your sympathy that's
basically what I all right guys there's
so much going on in the world
wow what a treat thank you for coming
thank you and what are you and what a
surprise to have you here slack in the
back they're really interesting inside
all you both you guys brave team I will
all be watching eagerly so yeah thank
you guys
oh yeah hoarding course absolutely how
could I not next week guys if anybody's
listening
nobody's would what I mean it's a it's a
crazy week we've got Papa John on Monday
and PewDiePie via satellite home oh yeah
that's outrage it's a crazy week oh and
then Friday we have Gus and Eddie you
know Gus yeah it's Friday yeah what day
is today that sounds he's like a sketch
comedy he's been oh he's really big on
reddit these real early it's real short
sketch man I'm gonna go check him out
he's good he's really funny cool god
that's all we got guys I mean we could
keep going but I think these guys
probably have some
the demon voice to say goodbye all right
go ahead and cut it yeah thank you guys
[Music]